foreign
[Music]
hey everybody it's Friday evening it's
me and Ming the merciless right here on
the side track
took you a second didn't it yeah I need
to make a man costume though you
probably should that would be a really
cool I mean that would be really cool
yeah I'm do my own version of me you
know what I mean yeah like some black
pants not a cape and just remember how
he was wearing that one military jacket
was red with black pants he's sitting
there watching his daughter get tortured
something like that
that would that would look good the big
long full dress Cape one
that's expensive it'd be hard to make
that one I mean it would be expensive to
make either one
but yeah the costumes and that were uh
were pretty badass but yeah they would
be kind of light-hearted
costumes are super [__] badass when
you see it on Blu-ray
and you see how good those those
costumes were on TV and CRT television
it wasn't high enough definition because
I remember seeing that movie in the
theater going man those costumes are
badass
and then a couple months later maybe six
months later remember they showed on
television I was like what that's not
even the same movie I [__] saw you
know yeah and the same thing with VHS
he'd run it on VHS and it never looked
as good as it did when you saw it on the
damn big screen
knocking [__] over
it's all right it won't hurt well no I'm
just worried it's going to spill that
onto the onto the laptop which would be
bad
let me go ahead and go over here and see
who's here Dave is here says hello
YouTube uh oh no makeup no going out
tonight yeah I mean yeah we're broke man
well I'm broke yeah
that may be it for this month
I got some but my refund my refunds
didn't come through yet they said it
could take up to two weeks for those
if I'd gotten those refunds maybe yeah
yeah
look at Pookie on the on the side track
yeah well I was kind of like like I said
just like it's hard to come up with a
title for the Side Tracks which is why I
just started putting the dates mostly
until I think of something else uh I
also don't know I wanted to change
because I kind of feel like for the side
track shows previously I always just put
the same
um thumbnail on there and I said well at
least want to change the picture out but
then again I'm running into the same
problem where I'm just kind of like well
I don't know what we're gonna talk about
so
so I'm just gonna have to put like some
random ass picture in there so that's
fine I just put Pokey in there Cookie's
good enough I mean she's usually on the
show popping her little head up right
there yeah at some point she was in here
earlier she asked us here how you been
sass
hey hey hey hey everybody
Tammy's in
Hugo
murder horn is just showing up
Zach Tom
rolling ghost faces in okay yeah the
regulars are all showing up
and uh we're gonna be here to um talk
you in very gently into the weekend
very gently there we go here we go
matter of fact I was going looking for
MSR last night and [__] uh stumbled
across a new new one that I've seen it's
just this dude and he's he's your friend
hello my friend you just got a deep
voice to get out of it he just brushes
your hair and [__] and I was looking in
the comment section brushes your hair
brushes your hair oh my God Pookie would
love that channel yeah I looked in the
comment section this is nothing but just
women loving on this dude [__] taking
him and he's just like I'm here to
protect you
I know things have been hard
and I'm looking at that and I [__] I
showed that to Sophie and I said soap
man look at this dude that says I need
this channel like this or just uh I'll
be in you should it's called and I'm
gonna call it [__] boyfriend
I'm gonna be like
how you doing baby it's good to see you
why are you dressed like that
oh you're going out
hold on one second let me get dressed
what do you mean I'm not going where are
you going Who you gonna be with
oh not an address
turn around oh hell no
you're hanging out the bottom of that
thing I'm never letting you out of this
house not looking the way you look
you're never gonna be able to defend
yourself against all that testosterone
you're standing right here
that's how it's gonna ask her boyfriend
that you know what that is a brilliant
yeah an idea I searched for it they
don't have it that's a brilliant okay
I'm gonna be like have you gained weight
hahaha come on now
let me go get the scale
think it'd work
I kind of love that I love that like a
satire of it yeah yeah yeah that's right
you have to like it would work if you do
it just like like you have to do it like
all dead pan and like really like
soothing sounding but you stand on his
scale right there damn [__] you're
getting fat
and none of it's going to your ass
either none of us I just just drive you
[__] crazy [__] boyfriend it's
gonna be a-s-o-e so [__] boyfriend
yeah because you can't okay yeah so
boyfriend I mean you can but you won't
be able to Monitor and not be your
boyfriend and just [__] with you
hahaha
see that is that is a brilliant idea I'm
good at it that's really been there
[Laughter]
you are not wearing that you've had
years and years and years of practice
you're not wearing that
that's not too flattering
that's exactly what you're like yeah
yeah
so it's like so it's kind of a joke but
not really would you wear something
shorter
let these [__] know what kind
of woman I'm with what you hiding for
I could do it either way
[Laughter]
you're either wearing not enough clothes
are you wearing too much clothes
well you could change it up you know
what I mean I mean that would be [__]
that's a great idea I think that's a
great idea yeah so and then now have the
[__] title so we're just outrageous
titles
[__] boyfriend
talks you into sleeping with his friends
to help pay to rent
[Laughter]
I might have a whole hour-long thing
where I'm gonna talk you into giving it
up and like I said making it
ASMR channel is also like a really good
angle on that I think that's a really
good idea like if you had like like I
could do like some really cool graphics
if we do the channel okay I'll do the
channel
okay you help do all the logistics
behind it
yeah
and I'd be talking sexy and [__] I mean
you have to come up with the scripts and
all that kind of stuff a lot about it
just off the top of my head that's what
I mean you could just do that but I'd
have to do like the rest of the stuff
yeah
judgy let judgy gay let the daddy
boyfriend
[Laughter]
baby how much you weigh we need to have
a talk that guy's it
trying to talk you into going on
steroids yeah that's another one yeah
yeah you can take it from your from from
your own experience
you don't even want to go to gym with me
so this is what's going to happen
gonna put you on test and then you're
going on Trend okay and you're gonna
have yeah I'll do it real slow though
I'll work it up to it yeah like dude you
have to do it like all like soothing and
sexy and stuff like that that's right in
the end what it is is you're gonna be
way and 225 pounds in the end of a
[__] two year period we're gonna have
you on a schedule and everything
I'm going to talk about the diet
and you know and that'd be a good
[__] uh gay MSR man a gay comedy amsr
well I just kind of feel like you could
probably do I mean you could put them
both on the same channel because you
could just like come out different roles
from like a bisexual yeah no just
different roles yeah that's videos
different that that dude was just doing
everything that dude was doing it the
dialogue was gender neutral you could
interpret it either way yeah you never
really but you see that's like smart
because you don't want to like you know
no it was mostly it was mostly girls
though responded to them and then like a
couple of guys were like oh man you got
me through a hard day and all that kind
of stuff
yeah
I'll be using the dark side on these
[__]
that would be funny as [__] yeah that
would be funny that's her boyfriend
turns you into a monster that's another
yeah just starts attacking your
insecurities and then flipping around or
we're gonna get Vengeance on these
people you know it will make us stronger
you know that kind of [__] man you
thought about this a lot no it's just
coming out right now
no I can make this [__] up quick
Zach says your roots are showing and not
the ones on your head
yeah okay
yeah we've got we got some gut iced tea
that has actual sugar in it this time
because he's like look usually we make
it with Splenda or whatever because it's
less calories but
he's like I don't really like the taste
of Splenda when you mix it with alcohol
so when he made the tea specifically to
mix with the Vodka he's like I'm gonna
put real sugar in that [__]
probably shouldn't have looked how many
calories were in a cup of sugar though
I did look and now I'm sorry I did but
oh well I'm not drinking a whole cup of
sugar right now well maybe I am I'm not
really sure
I'm back on train people
yeah I got my Trend today
he's very excited about it
[Laughter]
yeah I took 30 milligrams
we'll see how we'll see how it goes it's
not the same we can't watch any sad
movies not because we'll cry it's not
the same kind as I had last time this is
this is Trend Ace kind of a quicker
acting trend
it's weaker it's only 100 milligrams per
per milliliter so it's going to be not
as concentrated to give me them damp
irritations at the injection sites and
that yeah that was gross yeah and they
say but like alarming they say that you
kind of gain a little bit of a
resistance to it each time you go back
to it so we'll see how I emotionally
react to this it should make it
emotional as a [__] but I knew
what to expect I always know what to
expect so you can control it you just
he just sit there and just have to take
it man I'm feeling like a [__]
Trend makes you a [__]
like I said that's all that damn
progesterone that's how we feel is that
that's how you're gonna spell it [__]
boy no
ASO it just has to be asked because like
that people will say a-a-s-o-e
boyfriend amsr
I love that idea I think that's great I
think that's great let me make another
Channel like that yeah I think that
would be hilarious well you can make um
because I did offshoot channels from our
I don't know I'm sure there's a limit to
how many you can do like offshoot I mean
it's a it's its own channel but you can
have pretty much uh a whole bunch of
different channels like on the same
account you know what I mean so I could
just like start a new one okay but I
mean if you really want to do it if
you're going to put in like I said it's
a lot of work you know that right yeah
we'll take it we'll talk about it I'm
just saying it's a it's a cool idea it's
a good idea it has to be a totally
separate Channel though so we can keep
all the money separate so we know how
much money it's making
we'll see that's a problem that's gonna
have to be a different
um and which means it takes forever to
get it monetized too don't it well yeah
well not forever but you have to have a
thousand subscribers before you can
monetize it well the thing about it
though is that
um monetization like you like I could
start a new channel just on the same
account yeah but then all the money just
gets lumped together because it's the
same Google AdSense account because
that's how you get paid so you need like
a new Google ads but do you get um see
this is the problem if they could follow
it back to 13 o'clock then the joke
isn't as effective I I would think
because they go oh okay that's that dude
it's that dude that dude's a co-host and
[__] he's [__] with me it's got to be
something that it just seems to be
something on its own but that is that is
kind of a good idea
well maybe you shouldn't well don't like
sure your face then they don't do no I'd
show them maybe you should just do audio
no I'm gonna show my face well I'm just
saying that if you were that worried
about it then maybe like you wouldn't
you could just no I don't care if they
know that it's me I just I don't want a
stranger to know that I'm a host on
another show oh okay yeah because
because then they can't they they're
kind of like that's giving them behind
the scenes Peak
I'm gonna [__] with him right you know
I'm talking about I want to [__] with
them I don't really want to know who I
am I just want to remember just from
that channel okay just from that channel
yeah I gotcha so it's a unique
experience see
but it is kind of a maybe a better idea
to do it the way because you have
instant monetization the other way to do
it is you make like five or six videos
all right we put the channel up and it
would probably get a thousand it
probably would get a thousand
subscribers pretty quick maybe I mean
you know ASMR is like pretty it's
popular even but a lot of people yeah I
mean a lot of people do that but I mean
that's a different angle on it so some
people might like and it's funny so I
think people might it'll be comedy but
it will be amsr
it'll be comedy though but I don't want
to know it's comedy
right you know right they're going to
have to figure it out what I'm doing I'm
just [__] with them I mean you they
probably know like just if because it's
called asomorphins yeah I don't yeah
I mean you think I don't know if I'll
ever say the channel name they just have
to they just have to read it and realize
what it's saying
oh
my God I'll LARP on them yeah yeah
I mean that's a funny it's a funny idea
yeah although another be real rough be
real rough
yeah I love my friends
it's ugly as y'all are
I'm still happy to see you
first of all when's the last time y'all
showered
y'all steak
Yeah I mean like yeah say like you're
talking to one person yeah because like
I said the whole the whole theme yeah
that's gonna be one thing you gotta keep
it I gotta get I had to get in I had to
get into the roll yeah and each video
would have a different theme yeah so you
know yeah you could just talk about you
know the weight gain video yeah you're
getting too fast or the you're not going
out looking like a hoe yeah or like [__]
like that [__]
you ain't going nowhere
you pregnant doesn't
know because
actually that would be the good name of
it yeah yeah yeah yeah
[Laughter]
yeah that's a hilarious idea yeah and
I'll be like like in a wife beater like
this you know and some of them [__]
unshaven with [__] oil and grease and
[__] like I'm All Dirty you know some of
them just depending on what it is yeah
so you could like just rough see you
kind of like look like a look
I like see I like it a little sexy
scumbag
come here woman
turn around
who gave you that dress
I do I like this idea I like this idea
that's a good it's a good concept and I
don't think it's been I mean it could
have been done I looked for it and
didn't see it I don't know but I looked
for something like that yeah yeah I've
never seen anything like that I've seen
like some ASMR videos but they're
usually like pretty
I don't know if they're serious but you
know some of them are yeah but I want
one one one one
video is your ex-military boyfriend says
you need to work out that's another one
your ex-military boyfriend says you're a
piece of [__] or some something crazy
like that I have to talk I I have to I
have to craft those titles yeah if
there's just there's there's an art to
it it's almost gonna be like a Chuck
tank of of amsr but it's it's you got
you you understand exactly yeah yeah
yeah yeah I mean you can Envision it she
knows me so she knows what I'm thinking
yeah yeah I like yeah I like the Chuck
tingle angle too because that dude is a
[__] genius yeah I'm sorry but that I
mean
a genius a genius yeah
uh hey look full-time dead hello from
your favorite Circle K girl oh hey hey
what's up
where's the circle okay we see you're
[__] coming back in the club when we
go in there to get sandwiches buy a
microwave sandwiches well you get
microwaves yeah because I get cold ones
yeah yeah we're usually kind of drunk
but
I think we were pretty good yeah we're
not going out tonight we're staying in
yeah you know but yeah are you home
are you didn't you say that you weren't
gonna like work on weekends anymore or
something I thought she said that
but I don't remember I don't remember
Zach says Jenny solve a problem uh oh
I've been called upon good I'm trying to
come up with a plausible amateur
investigation into a missing person for
a story and I don't know how to tackle
it like are you talking about you want a
justification for a character to do like
an amateur investigation I mean they
could be a relative or they could be
a private investigator or something like
that I mean I would think like maybe a
relative would be the easiest to
understand like maybe that's their
sister or something like that I mean I
know it's been done before but there's a
reason it's been done before because
it's something that's believable and
would probably happen I don't know if
that's what you're talking about though
wait no but I thought pookie was back
there
says since he was up go get me another
beer
the your channel yes he's giving you
some ideas all kinds of some ideas
possessive boyfriend says
[Laughter]
possessive boyfriend says you can't see
that guy that's uh there's all kinds of
stuff you can't be or no possessive
boyfriend says
you're not going anywhere that's one of
the things yeah that was one of the
things you're not leaving this house
you're not leaving this house
I'll come up with all questions
you're not leaving this house I like it
I like it yeah I just the more I think
about it I'm like yeah that I that's a
that's a concept that could totally live
all different well because I've known
you for such a long time and it's like
that is exactly like right in your
wheelhouse
no I'm just saying that like you'd be
really good at just like sitting here
like coming up with all of this stuff
you know what I mean that would be
[__] hilarious
yeah
full-time dad says I'm luckily off
tonight for a change using the husband's
account to watch you guys oh we're so
glad that like she did the circle Okay
girl okay yeah okay we're so glad that
you're here
that's so cool yeah we just we just saw
her last Friday when we were buying
something which is I was buy the same
thing I get chicken chicken salad and
cranberry
and then a little kid a little mini can
of Pringles yeah
Kaylin Higgins says ASMR has never
worked on me
probably a form of uh misophonia I guess
they is it misophonia misophonia when
people talk directly into my ear yeah
it's not
um
I get it but I don't think it does it
doesn't really do anything for me either
you know what I mean it only works it
only works on me if there's an accent
if the person has an accident they don't
have anything does it matter what kind
of accent or just anything if it's Asian
or like Chinese or Korean or Japanese
into an accent that's relaxing
um
nobody else really can do it I mean I
don't mind it it's like it doesn't like
bother me or anything like that but it's
like it doesn't really because I kind of
feel like some people get really into it
like ooh it's really relaxing to be
honest like I don't like any noise when
I'm sleeping you know what I mean
there's something about it's too
distracting like it'll just wake me up
and it's not just like an accent like a
French accent that's not gonna [__]
do it or a German it's it's there's
something about the mispronunciations
that is relaxing I don't know maybe
partially kind of growing up in Korea
maybe that's what I was gonna say
because you lived there for a little bit
here and these mispronounced common
mispronunciations that they did it's
really interesting yeah and maybe it
kind of yeah well maybe it's kind of
like reminding you going back to an
earth of a period in your life that you
like really enjoyed it was really
relaxing
uh have you tried the Wawa turkey dinner
sub it has turkey and cranberry on it I
haven't but it's like I keep like people
keep telling me because man all those
like Thanksgiving sandwiches those are
the [__] but it's like I've never
everybody tells me like how good Wawa
stuff is but I've never been there we
have ones around here well actually I
don't know
where's the closest Wawa to here I don't
even know
I mean closest thing to Circle K
obviously but um we have two Circle K's
actually just like a mile from our house
but we have Wawas but I've never been in
there but I know a lot of people like
really like their uh their stuff you
know what I mean
cool thank you got more ice our little
ice maker is
yeah it said there's a Wawa in Mount
Dora on 441. yeah I'm pretty sure we
passed it at some point but I've never
been I don't think I've ever been in a
Wawa in my whole entire life which is
crazy they're good they got all kinds of
stuff in there that's what everybody
says I mean but that's the thing it's
just kind of like nowadays you can't
just be I mean unless you're out in the
sticks in the middle of nowhere and you
don't have a choice of where to go but
it's like convenient stories you can't
really be
you can't really have like shitty food
anymore really you know what I mean you
have to like kind of step your game up
because everybody else did yeah even
Circle K is pretty good
I've honestly to be honest like when
we're whenever we're kind of like uh
inebriated and we're kind of like always
stop at Circle K because like I said
it's right there by the house yeah and
so we stopped there to get sandwiches
and I've always got like cold sandwiches
I usually get chicken salad and
cranberry or egg salad or something like
that and every single one of those has
been delicious like the bread is like
super pillowy soft and all nice and
fresh really good yeah and Circle K is
nothing really all that special it's
about like 7-Eleven I would think that
some 7-Elevens actually some of the
7-Elevens are even nicer although there
are some nice Circle K's out there a lot
of it has to do with the with the
location yeah because we're kind of out
in a rural area yeah and these are old
Circle K's that they have here
they've been here for a long time a
couple decades some of them
yeah and we have like I said we have two
like right across like caddy corners
from each other yeah which I'm not quite
sure why they did that but I guess it's
going either way I guess traffic going
either way but yeah it is kind of weird
but I don't know well that's the thing
like
um 7-Eleven I used to eat stuff from
7-Eleven all the time because it was one
like right next door to my work like you
could it was literally across the
parking lot wild boss pretty good but up
the road there's a race track
racetrack's real nice
I don't know if I've ever yeah I've seen
them but I don't know if I've ever been
up so I've gotten gas at them but I
don't think I've ever gone in there and
like bought food that racetrack that
they have up there is kind of like going
into Starbucks but you can like buy a
little bit of groceries and stuff you
know I mean there's coolers in there but
they have like Fresh Sandwiches and food
and
I think there's like a salad bar or some
[__] like that something was there
maybe not a salad bar that's the thing
it's like I think it was a [__] it
was kind of you know although Circle K
kind of has that too places I think they
have like little nachos she can tell you
well in the 7-Eleven I used to go to had
kind of like a small little cooler that
had like all fresh food they had like
little salads and fruit and like little
packages that had like nuts and cheese
and stuff like that but racetrack had we
passed a racetrack on the back from back
of mannequins
on the right we're across the street
from McDonald's right right before I-4
yeah yeah that's right on the right is a
huge race that's right I don't think
I've ever been to that one though yeah
it's new Victor says one time I fell
asleep to ASMR playing on YouTube then
woke up all scared when it auto played
the videos of 9-1-1 calls
what a weird thing for it to go to
afterward you would think that ASMR it
would like just go to another ASMR video
but I don't know Kailyn said what's the
nicest fast food place you've ever been
to
ooh Panera
well that's kind of that's not fast food
that's considered fast casual okay those
are two different classes that's like in
the same class as like Chipotle okay
because you go up and you order food and
you take it then you like you take it's
not like they don't have a drive-through
or anything like that I think some
Paneras have a drive-through but I don't
think most we got Kick-Ass McDonald's
here man I love that they're pretty
McDonald's uh food is good yeah it's all
right you can order on touch screens now
you don't have to wait in line
um
the Interiors are pretty nice
and uh McDonald's is always the same
it's consistent okay that's one of the
things yeah that's kind of one of their
big things like sometimes I just want a
Big Mac I said just give me two Big Macs
so you don't want any sense it's a no no
no just two Big Macs that's it they'll
sit there and just wolf those things
down it's the secret sauce all that
lettuce for some reason I think that's
what's attracted me to that sandwich
um
you could probably take one of those
meat patties off I probably wouldn't
even notice it
probably not yeah I saw a short video
earlier today that was there's a really
good channel that I'm subscribed to I
think it's called weird history food and
um they had like cool fast food [__]
from like around the world you know what
I mean yeah where you know it's the same
fast food chains that we have but they
have like different [__] and one of the
things they had was McDonald's in where
the [__] was this
damn it now I can't remember I think it
was in Italy oh it was in Italy
McDonald's in Italy has a Nutella burger
like it's a dessert Burger it's not like
an actual hamburger okay but it's like
kind of a slightly sweeter bun with like
Nutella it actually looks really good
and I think there was one McDonald's and
I think it was in
I want to say it was Singapore but I
could be wrong
they had you could order the french
fries but the french fries had like
um
was it chocolate syrup and like pumpkin
spice on them sounds terrible no I was
like no that sounds really good they
said that's well because french fries
have salt on them or sugar salt
we'll see salt and chocolate is really
really good together I'd have to try it
like I just I used to get sauce for me
man no no no like sometimes I got like
um
for a while like um this one mail order
place I used to get chocolate covered
potato chips like chocolate covered
potato chips are delicious
and so when I saw that I was like yeah I
mean the french fries are so good just
on their own that it almost seems a
shame to put something up but I think
that would be kind of good because like
I said salty potatoes like potato chips
and stuff like that are really good like
with chocolate on them
so I don't know it sounded kind of good
to me most of the McDonald's locations
in Florida especially around the more
popular areas touristy areas Orlando and
stuff they're real good
um
Burger King sucks here it's it's very
mediocre we go because they just
basically give that [__] away for free
if you have coupons it's cheap and it's
like on our way to it's on our way to
places like the the movie theater and
stuff like that it's like but it's very
mediocre
um
I haven't been to a Wendy's here
I don't I I don't know I always thought
Wendy's was pretty decent yeah I like
Wendy's better than Burger King that's
for sure oh yeah yeah
um what else was good here in terms of
fast food
um
she took me to Del Taco I haven't been
to a Del Taco since I was out in
California but the Del Taco here was
[__] great it's just that it's far
real far we only have two Del Tacos as
far as I know there's one in Winter Park
over way the [__] over by UCF and I
don't remember where the other one is
like because I used to go to that Del
Taco not all the time but it's like I
had a friend that lived out over there
and we would go there yeah you know
after the club if we were going back to
her house so we would go there but and
that's kind of like close to where I
used to live when I lived by myself but
it's really really far from here it's
American tacos
but they're good okay they're not like a
Mexican taco
I would say they're calmex tacos that
have been even more Americanized uh but
they blows [__] Taco Bell out of the
water much better like three times Taco
Bell's the same thing over and over
again just in a different shape and
different different quantities but you
have to give them props for like coming
up with it it's like look we have like
five different ingredients and we can
put them in different configurations and
just name them something else
it works their stuff's okay I'm not like
a huge Taco Bell fan but yeah Taco Bell
was great when you could get like 20
tacos for five bucks because the only
thing that I like are the [__] just
the regular tacos like the hard tacos
just a lot of hard taco the things that
they used to be for 30 cents each
remember those back when we were kids
like 25 cents for a [__] Taco like
yeah five dollars and here's 20 of them
in a big old [__] basket sit there
and just
with that cheap Picante hot sauce
it's just
it's like White Castle you know which I
like White Castle and Crystal those were
the original mer those were the original
hamburgers
sometimes I mean they give me really bad
heartburn but I like them it must be the
onions they're even better when you're
drunk
well that's true of most food like that
if you laid out all kinds of good
[__] food if I'm drunk I'd probably
give me any White Castles yeah I
probably would too now give me give me
give me nine of them or ten of them you
know it would either be that or honestly
when I'm drunk you know what I usually
want I want a [__] breakfast buffet
yeah I'm like I want some [__] I want
an omelette and like some pancakes and
some waffles with whipped cream on it it
was great because
on our way back from the club back
before the covet and the [__] I guess
the normal world ended
the McDonald's right there near our
house on the on our old house on the way
back from the club
started to do Egg McMuffin at night and
I get like yeah they did breakfast food
all night yeah and we were like
Hallelujah yeah because that's what I
always wanted yeah
it's like all I want is a sausage and
with muffin with egg when I'm drunk and
maybe a hash brown should we come back
from the club lay up in that big [__]
king-sized [__] Posturepedic [__]
air mattress before that thing fell
apart eventually yeah we don't have that
anymore I probably get another one we
just we just left it at the old house
because yeah food away oh you did I
couldn't leave it there
got to take it apart and then they broke
it up and they took it yeah okay it
didn't have much life left in it anyway
all the woods started to warp in it and
the [__] mattresses started to Spring
leaks
yeah I had to go in there and [__]
patch it but that [__] fat bit was
great
um when it was before it got too old but
anyway uh we'd sit up there in that big
king-sized bed watching Danville on the
[__] yeah because we always just put
dancing on because I'm like well that's
always like his voice is just so relaxed
well see there's another ASMR thing
eating Mig McMuffins Dan Bell doesn't
even have an ASMR Channel but his voice
is just kind of like very very soothing
I tried a molester and [__] she'd go nah
nah we talking about
not always well a lot of times I'm like
now I'm all greasy and I'm like super
drunk and looking like super tired
because usually it was like three or
four double pricing their boobs up and
I'm just like
[Laughter]
it's fine fine time
Victor said I hate you looking at us
what are you guys doing yeah she's
always like what what is that she always
makes that face
she always looks surprised at stuff she
doesn't understand anything like when
she walks in she's like yeah believe it
she can't [__] believe it yeah that's
funny
she's always like that yeah
Victor says I ate at McDonald's in Paris
and was disappointed that they didn't
have Royale with cheese yeah maybe they
don't do that anymore what do they call
it then yeah that was the uh Quarter
Pounder
trying to think of now see I'm gonna say
the Big Mac is okay but I'm gonna say
the real unsung MVP of McDonald's
hamburger menu is the quarter pounder I
would argue that the quarter pounder is
better than the big man
yeah but well that's the thing about
opinions like different people there's
no objective reality here I'm just
saying that it's like I personally I
think the quarter pounder is better
although honestly if I Double Quarter
Pounder is pretty good well yeah yeah
I'm talking about yeah I'm talking about
but the thing about it though is like if
I'm going to McDonald's like if I want a
hamburger I'll usually get a quarter
pounder
with or without cheese I don't really
care either way but honestly I like
their crispy chicken sandwiches the one
with the club the one with the uh tomato
and lettuce and all the veggies on it
and stuff like that I like that so if
I'm gonna get like a sandwich I'll
usually get that or the fish filet of
fish is good too but the double filet of
fish is better so they're asking what's
the best fast food in Florida
oh and Tammy said does your McDonald's
serve biscuits and gravy no no oh wait
it's honestly there [__] us over with
the breakfast food they [__] us over
with breakfast food but I'm talking
about the interiors and the quality of
what they do give you is nice here it's
always hot
well at least the locations we go to
you know they were over near our house
and we lived in a real nice area so I
think yeah it depends on the location
depends on just like everything else
because the thing about it is
franchising who's managing it yeah you
know all that other kind of stuff so if
it's in kind of like
a really nice neighborhood you know it's
our newer area
so everything yeah it's probably gonna
be like slightly nicer it's probably
gonna be nicer because the standards
wouldn't yeah the older areas because
they're gonna just be run down you know
what I mean the energy really isn't
there and the there's Pookie the money
isn't older run down areas the money and
the money in the revenue isn't there to
keep up
yeah so it's like they don't really have
no money in it yeah well they probably
don't have the money to invest they
don't like fix things up or [__] we put
money in this the [__] business is
petering out you know what I mean
everything's nothing's permanent here in
America nothing I think that's what
happened to the Burger King that we
always went to yeah
and the burger it's not in a terrible
area it's just it's in a real built up
um I mean it was in pretty much the same
kind of area there's like a really nice
restaurant there there's a Starbucks
there's a bunch of other [__] but that
Burger King has been there it's right
off the
off of I-4 yeah remembering [__] Back
to the Future too and Back to the Future
[__] Marty wanted to move over to
Hilldale and hit that's his dream house
was in the new housing complex that they
were building I think it was called
Hilldale Hilldale wasn't it I don't
remember it's been a while he wants to
you know his dream is to have that down
four by four and to marry that girl and
go live in that housing complex and it's
[__] awesome you know uh as it's
being built and then he goes into a
[__] parallel dimension
you know parallel timeline 20 years down
the road and that place is the [__]
Hood it's [__] up
they got crime scene [__] tape and
[__] and all the all the cars are [__]
up a lot of them in the United States is
like that they'll build an area that was
nice in the 80s but now
that place is a Rat's Nest you know
because the business that fueled that
area is gone now you know so the people
that made money moved away and then that
all became lower income and not worth as
much so they didn't treat it as well and
then people who don't work for a living
are in there they can't afford anything
and it just [__] just everything just
falls apart I mean some of those people
work for a living they just work like
shitty jobs they don't Shady jobs don't
pay anything so they can't keep up with
anything because they can't pay bills
and then do upkeep at the same and why
worry about upkeep when your neighbor's
house is a [__] Rat's Nest you know
what I mean you could your [__] could
look awesome as [__] it's not going to
change property value
just because that area so the United
States nothing nothing's permanent
everything's temporary you have to be
able to move
because the economy is constantly moving
around but see that's the shitty thing a
lot of people can't I mean moving is
expensive yeah but you know life isn't
about making things easy for you it's
the struggle of survival just like the
damn [__]
Animal Kingdom and then you have a
ruling class and Leadership that gives a
[__] about you they only care about the
money that they're making over in China
all right and it'll continue to be that
way until y'all stop it and y'all won't
stop it you're not smart enough that's
just how it is
they know what they're doing that's the
predatory class and the
the predatory class at the very top are
also parasites they don't really do
anything
when they talk about these poor people
being parasites nah it's those rich
people those are the true parasites well
yeah it does not the ones they're
sucking us all dry
John Gore said I get sick after five
McDonald's fries feel hungover the next
day oh I feel sorry for you I mean I
really do like McDonald's oh those are
the best french fries you can get is
McDonald's and I mean all the patented
the damn French I mean french fries yeah
all french fries are pretty good
um and all the all the big chains have
decent french fries but
this might be a slightly controversial
opinion I kind of like slightly soggy
french fries I like soggy more than
crispy
no I like a mixture I like and I like
big french fries like I will remember
like way a long time ago I don't even
know [__] that would be Wendy's I think
it's like that no I think Wendy's are
kind of more well wait are Wendy's like
bigger I've never wear these in a long
time but it's like a really long time
ago KFC used to have like big like
potato planks or potato wedges yeah I'm
into that because I really like the
potato she was she was asking what's the
best fast food all right and I'm gonna
answer that
if Panera is not fast food that's fast
casual that's a different class to me I
call that fast food but I'm gonna go
ahead and give you that and say okay no
I'm just saying like from an industry
standpoint that's considered a different
class
it's about the same though it doesn't
have a drive through I think that's the
main difference yeah most of them know I
do like Panera a lot though I would say
the best fast food would be Chick-fil-A
they got a great fly different fries
real good sandwiches they're taking your
order as you're driving up to the
windows they got girls down in there
taking their orders to the you'll see a
huge line
four cars wide all right going out
[__] 10 cars deep and that and that's
only like a couple minutes wait that's
how fast they can
get a bunch of traffic in and out of a
[__] well-oiled
um Chick-fil-A Chick-fil-A kicks ass
really good employees
good food a chicken sandwich is super
good even though they've changed it
used to be a damn pressure cooked
chicken patty
with with uh um uh [__]
dough around it what am I calling it
crust spreading it's ready
now it's baked but it used to be
pressure cooked in oil
but I made a minute for Jenny this is
yeah you can make them at home you can
make them at home you take a chicken
breast and you soak it at least one
night in pickle juice that's what
they're doing they take it out
egg wash roll it in um flour that's been
salted seasoned flour which is salt and
pepper
put it in a pressure cooker
pour like two cups of oil in it and
pressure cook them all you might have
like six or six of them in there four or
five of them in there
only for like a couple minutes and then
when the pressure goes down you pull
them out and they're they're perfect
they're those the old school
Chick-fil-A Patty and you just put them
on a steamed bun with a pickle
and that shit's [__] good with mayo
man
yeah I kind of feel like they
um
they they add new things but they try to
keep their menu as small as possible
yeah which you know if you do not soak
that chicken breast in pickle juice at
least one night you will not have that
Chick-fil-A taste not the one that's how
they get that that's how they get that
yeah they brine at it yep
and like you said back in the old days
because I remember eating there as a kid
because there was one in the mall and my
grandma always liked to eat there yeah
and um yeah they did used to pressure
cook them pressure cooked and I don't
think they do that anymore no not
anymore they're trying to make it more
low-fat and that's kind of a harder
slower way of doing it they're just
pre-cooking them all they've been baking
them they must have some kind of air
fryer that's probably what they're
probably what they're using yeah you can
do a lot of them that way
um but no you if you want the old school
Chick-fil-A that [__] was pressure
cooked in oil
which I didn't know that was possible
until I researched how they did that
and I've done it which yeah I mean it's
a lot more fattening but yeah
as with most things it's more fattening
therefore it tastes better and they
recommend that's just because the
universe hates us that's that's how that
works and they recommended peanut oil if
I remember correctly
I think peanut yeah with the oil that
they used that makes sense yeah
Zach says I'm always interested in
different types of fast food in other
countries some of it sounds really good
yeah I mean I see some of these videos
sometimes that it's like hey like in
other countries they have this that and
the other thing I'm like God damn it
when are we gonna have that honestly
like I would eat the [__] out of french
fries with like chocolate and pumpkin
spice stuff on there I would eat that
and they had this other thing too I
think this was also in Asia somewhere
but I don't was it Pizza Hut or Domino's
I can't remember I think it was Pizza
Hut but they had like a p like pizza
section they had like a pizza inside a
pizza yeah whereas like the pizza was
like this like a normal pizza but then
like you would kind of come in there was
like toppings and whatnot and then like
inside of it there was like a another
pizza so there was like another crust in
there with like different [__] on it
like in the middle you know what I'm
talking about yeah so they had that I'm
like that sounds it's funny because that
[__] sounds like so [__] American but
some of the [__] that like other fast
food places in other countries have
sounds like way more American than
American [__] our shit's boring over
here like compared because like I've
seen some of the [__] over there I'm
like God damn it why don't we have that
holy [__] that sounds amazing yeah they
have um
they have a different Market there
because
um
the American market for fast food is is
pretty kind of low income
people don't want to spend a whole lot
of money in a fast food joint because
they're not exotic here that's just
normal [__] in another country something
like a McDonald's for certain countries
has seen as something for an exotic so
that market is willing to drop 20 bucks
a person in something that you get out
of McDonald's so they could give they
could sell them anything anything exotic
Japan sells [__] at KFC that they would
never sell here
that's Japan's got some crazy ideas but
they do
it is pretty good evidently like okay
the Japanese
they want uh I think it's either
Christmas dinner or Thanksgiving I think
I don't remember which one it was I
think it's Christmas dinner and for
Christmas dinner and they don't have
Christmas they're not Christians okay
uh but they celebrate Christmas it
caught on like a fad
well you know because it's fun yeah but
they think for Christmas you eat
Kentucky Fried Chicken so can so
Kentucky Fried Chicken
promotes Christmas yeah they lean into
that yeah and they uh so in when you're
in Japan KFC owns Christmas
and it was a good idea they've been
doing that for a long time that isn't
anything new and it's because evidently
like the the president
of KFC Japan
grew up in the United States I think he
actually went to Harvard University
and
his all of his college Years he spent
here and that one of the things he liked
was Christmas
so he helped take that to Japan and
catered to it
and evidently
Christmas was brought to Japan through
KFC
that was you know they promoted
Christmas
made it a bigger deal no I made it a big
deal yeah it's Christmas time come get
some chicken
and if you look at the chicken that they
saw it is kind of like a turkey dinner
that the Americans would eat at
Christmas kind of
there's still a lot of the same sides
they've just substituted the turkey for
chicken yeah which like I said it's not
it's not that weird I mean I think that
if you're here to us when we think about
it well no because I kind of feel like
if somebody told me it's like oh we had
chicken you know we had a Christmas
dinner and it's like we went to KFC and
had it catered and you just had fried
chicken but then you had like mashed
potatoes and I'm like most of that [__]
is like similar we would eat so it's
like I don't think that would be like I
think they have stuffing and cranberry
sauce with it you know what I mean which
that would work yeah why not work with
friends it's still poultry yeah I mean
the fact that it's fried but you know
it's Thanksgiving like some people deep
fry their turkeys right so you know what
I mean I don't think it's that strange I
don't think it's that strange well it's
just I think it's strange that
KFC brought
Christmas to Japan
in other words a lot of a lot of
Japanese were almost kind of KFC and
Christmas are synonymous in the mind of
a lot of Japanese like okay yeah which
that kind of happened to here in the
United States in terms of Coca-Cola
Coca-Cola seemed to have owned Christmas
this goes back all the way like the 20s
and the 30s
because evidently Coca-Cola was kind of
responsible for Reviving Christmas
Christmas wasn't really a day in the
early 1900s I mean it was around but it
wasn't a big [__] corporate national
holiday
and Coca-Cola started to make signs with
Santa Claus on them big fat Santa Claus
with the red suit which is evidently a
Coca-Cola invention
part is like fat Santa partly yeah
or at least they made that popular yeah
that's like a whole fascinating history
like how that's kind of so Santa Claus
brought to you by the Coca-Cola Company
well the thing about Christmas was that
what a lot of people maybe don't know is
that Christmas was actually in the early
days of the United States was illegal
Christmas celebrations
for Puritans and stuff like that yeah
because uh legally even celebrating
sacrilegious pagan holidays and [__]
yeah because it was seen as a pagan
holiday
it didn't really catch on I feel like
until the the late 19th century
you know it became christianized
yeah
uh let's see full-time dad says well
with the forty dollars I spent on dinner
tonight I could get two days worth of
food from fast food yeah you probably
could uh the pricing for cooking
yourself is astronomical
yeah I guess it depends on what you make
like I'm really fascinated by it depends
on where you live that's you I mean it's
getting high here compared to what it
was but it's nowhere near as high as it
is in California I'm always really
fascinated by channels that um
kind of are like uh you know feed
yourself for ten dollars this week or
something like that that's like extreme
budgets I'm really interested like to
see what they come up with like what you
can eat for like not that much money you
know what I mean because you know I
lived alone and I didn't have a lot of
money for a while and it's like it's
just interesting how
like what different stuff you can make
with like kind of really really cheap
ingredients I mean not surprisingly a
lot of it has to do with like beans and
rice because those things are like
pretty cheap to buy in bulk but you know
it's kind of interesting the [__] they
come up with I'm just always really
interested I'm interested in how people
take limitations like that and like do
creative [__] with it I guess that's why
I'm interested in that kind of stuff I'm
pretty uh
pretty concerned with nutrition though
and if it's not protein it's not really
all that food like
just based on what I see
like Dollar General Store the best
proteins you can give are cheap right
now still canned tuna
and spam and people hold their nose up
at spam because they don't [__] they're
talking about spam is a good cut of meat
it's pork shoulder all right it's just
been deboned and cooked in that can
the problem with Spam is is that it's
got a lot of brine in it so it tends to
be real salty but they have a lot of
different flavors
I got [__]
Teriyaki flavors and all kinds of stuff
I have them in storage the spam it was
the original MRE
and uh it's [__] pure protein and a
soldier would eat the whole [__] can
of spam at one sitting because you
couldn't set you couldn't reclose the
clan man I'm sweating just thinking
about that yeah I eat the whole thing
yeah but you know they were in combat I
know but they probably only ate once a
day and maybe didn't eat every day
depending on what battle they were in
but um
no
so I'm looking at what they have down
there you know some of the stuff I buy
because I start stockpiling stuff just
in case like I got the Spam single so
you can get them for a dollar fifty
which is kind of kind of high for the
amount of spam that's in there but it's
flat and it's in metal packaging that's
as good as an MRE so you could carry
that with you in a pack
but I got cans too
and then Velveeta is also selling metal
foil packs of cheese sauce which is
which is whey protein
which is just like they used to give us
[__] like that similar to the Army we
eat it on crackers or we would put it in
in a in a Ramen if we were cooking which
is not an MRE but we would carry Ramen
with us too and cook it up in canteen
cups
and you had to have some kind of protein
well that Velveeta cheese is protein
same thing you make out of protein
shakes
so those things are only a dollar a pack
there's all kinds of stuff out there
that if you pay attention to the back
they're worth worthwhile I'd rather have
Vienna sausage than
which that's [__] bottom of the
barrel right there
but the packaging is correct it's
indestructible it's a single kind of
serving and you are getting some protein
in there
for a dollar something I'd rather have
that than beans
then you get beanie weenie
it's another one and you want something
that has a pull top on it so most of the
stuff I get for any kind of survival or
camping stuff has to have a pull top
you can carry a can opener so a lot of
my Knives have [__] can openers on
them you can get good with it but it's
nice to just have a pool top
um but no everything's getting expensive
I can't believe the eggs are as
expensive as they are
and well that was one thing because I've
been watching
um a couple of the the women that I
watch they
um they haven't been getting as many
eggs a lot of times they'll just get
fewer and they'll just like make them
stretch farther but one thing they like
to do not so much with
um you know stuff that'll last forever
but they're just talking about hey how
can you eat for a week on you know just
going to Dollar General or whatever A
lot of the time what they'll do for meat
is
um they'll get one of those little chubs
of like turkey sausage or pork sausage
yeah and they'll use that in like three
different meals you know what I mean
because they can use that in a lot of
stuff but like tuna is good too
full-time dad says I'm making a potato
soup with mushrooms kale sausage carrots
and onions and heavy cream and chicken
broth that actually sounds good
delicious I'm gonna eat the [__] out of
that now another thing is is that uh
dairy's starting to get expensive
and it's going to be expensive until
this [__] is ever over which I don't
really think it will be not my lifetime
but um
we're gonna see
anyway uh I found recently that if you
go to uh Walmart or a place like that
you can find powdered milk by Neato
which is a real common in Central and
South America
Nido
another one is Kim k-i-l-m which is milk
spelled backwards and they're they're
Nestle and big brands that make those
and it's expensive a big big metal can
of it
but when you actually kind of do the
math they make several gallons of milk
but it lasts a lot longer it doesn't
require refrigeration and you don't have
a gallon of milk sitting in your
refrigerator rotten away
because you mostly going to use milk for
recipes so you're taking it out of there
a spoonful at a time making some milk to
complete a recipe
every now and then I'll drink it it's
good it's just as good I think it's if
you if you have the you can make it a
little bit thicker and I think it's just
as if as long as it's chilled it's just
as good as stuff that came out of a
carton
um you can tell there's a difference but
I mean I don't really drink milk out of
a glass anymore so I don't really care
it's not that good for you it's got a
lot of lactic acid in it which is not
really all that good for you
um
but it is nutritious especially in you
know
if you're working hard kind of like
starvation stuff
but uh so I recommend powdered milks
we've even gotten powdered coconut milk
I'll get that at the Indian store for
like the Indian spice yeah for like
really cheap and I found a way to order
it too
because we used to get that we used to
get like big boxes of like the powdered
coconut milk and youth that would last
for like ages yeah and that's for making
things like Thai curry yeah because you
can just you put it in a [__] uh
measuring cup with like hot water and
just like mix it up you can make some
coconut milk and then put it into the
recipe yeah Linwood Sly how you doing uh
mannequins Lounge 407 Sanford Avenue is
where you guys visit in case I'm in town
one day yeah that's it yeah it's in
downtown Sanford which is a nice little
place it's tiny there's just like a
couple box of blocks but there's like
some cool [__] down there that place is
packed most of the time on weekend
nights yeah well because there's a lot
of a lot of restaurants and there's a
lot of bars and there's a lot of stuff
down there man it's just like a nice
little area mannequins has become kind
of like a local novelty slash attraction
well we went there last Friday this was
crazy like because usually we get there
Friday we got there slightly later than
usual but not really and usually when we
get there it takes a while like for it
to fill up but when we got there last
week last Friday night
um there was a ton of people there
already scandily clad baby bats and
apparently yes it was just kind of like
there was a lot there was a contingent
of very very young gods in there yeah
and they who most of the whom I had
never seen before and they knew all the
[__] man because he played like some old
stuff he played like old Ministry old
cramps it's like they knew all that [__]
yeah and I was just kind of like oh yeah
they knew the Ramones they knew they
knew all the words they were just like
just singing along and jumping up and
down and I was like that is like pretty
awesome but if you go on Google and
everything and just look up mannequins
spelled with K am I how do you spell
m-a-n-n-i-k-i-n-s I think it was just
one in one end okay uh he spelled it all
weird
and I thought I knew it was spelled
weird anyway
yeah but I mean it's not spelled like it
would normally be yeah if you were using
it like it right so
um if you look at the it's got real good
reviews and those are reviews from
normies they love it you know because to
them I
a lot of people that go in there I've
never seen anything like that yeah
yeah the main nights of Friday and
Saturdays Friday is the main like goth
night and then there's yeah the Friday
is kind of more tense toward
like goth and old like Punk and stuff
like that Saturday nights is more kind
of like everything yeah like he'll just
play whatever
like from stuff like that to
I'm dressing dudes down in there too man
they have these goth girls out there you
know and they're young
and these uh dude Bros will [__] get
drunk and jump out there and try to
dance with him and I'll [__] Jump and
Go no no no not with those shoes
[Laughter]
because I'm more jacked than them and
I'm like what this is not this is your
dad talking you know don't cut you
you're gonna come in here you come in
here with some game not not with those
shoes man [__] oh okay come here with
the Crocs and [__] Crocs and [__]
white shoes and [__] looking like a Jack
boy you grab those things they're not
looking for you dude baggy khakis I mean
they might be looking for you but not
dressed like that you better understand
the culture you know you can't just come
in here and throw in your [__] dick
around on these [__] girls nobody can
dance either they can't dance you can't
dance they don't know the music they
don't know the culture they don't know
the dress code
you know
[Laughter]
[__] white sneakers and [__] well
like I said it's like if you're gonna I
I don't know I'm not a real like
attention [__] kind of person so what
oh all right
good
Sly is in there what's up oh that was
like super lemony yeah
yeah he mixed in some like country time
like powder
at the end because we didn't have any
lemon juice
so I got all of it I like women I'm not
complaining I'm just saying
but yeah so
I don't know like like I said I'm not a
real like attention Horry kind of person
so I don't really like understand people
that just come in somewhere and are like
hey I'm here you know what I mean and
they're like hey I'm gonna go in the
middle of the dance floor and like start
flailing my arms around and like acting
like a jackass and like everyone will
admire me I guess is what they think but
you know I don't know
so I don't really know what they're
thinking if if indeed they're thinking
anything at all maybe they aren't
that would explain a lot actually
um yeah okay yes I said Thank you guys
yeah that's where it is it's um
yeah I mean downtown Sanford it's like I
said it's tiny it's only like a few
blocks but it's actually pretty cool
like there's a lot of really good
restaurants and there's a lot of German
restaurants for some reason I'm not
really sure why
um a lot of German restaurants there's a
really good uh used book and record
stored in there called Maya I think it's
called it's two stories it's like all
books on the uh ground floor and it's
all records on the you know vinyl
records on the second floor and it's
really really cool I've been in there a
bunch of times a lot of little like
boutiques like art gallery type stuff
and like places that have like cool
little jewelry and plays it's like it's
really really cool
um talk about Waffle House man we
haven't been a Waffle House in a long
time Waffle House we used to thank you
Jeffy art I like your little workout is
that a pair
fist bump it's the fist bump pair thank
you
but
um
we used to go to Waffle House a lot
because it was on the way back to where
Tom used to live like before we moved in
together like he lived in a townhouse in
Altamonte Springs and there was a Waffle
House just like right like maybe half a
mile like up the street from where he
lived so that was usually that was open
all night obviously so we would usually
stop in there
um but yeah Waffle House is pretty good
too
you know
what happened making sure it mixed well
enough it's hard to mix you know it's
great
that's what I said like that that last
like uh mouthful that I got was like
sending this money thank you yeah it was
like super lemony but that's okay
I think it's a pair it looks like a pear
that's what I thought it was it's like a
pair with legs
he's super cute though I like his little
face and his and his little lover boy
headband I'm into that
oh
my God I started watching a show I just
like started watching this randomly on
Netflix last night because I was bored
and I was just kind of like oh what's
this because I love [__]
cooking shows we'll see here okay
what's been happening is that I've been
watching the latest
season of Hell's Kitchen the Gordon
Ramsay show
but we don't have cable so I usually
watch on Hulu and a lot of times because
I think it comes on live like Wednesday
night maybe like on whatever [__]
channel it's on
so usually Hulu will have it the next
night so Hulu will show it like we'll
have it on there Thursday night
but sometimes not and I don't really
know why
sometimes it's there sometimes you gotta
wait like several days sometimes it's
like a week I don't know
so last night I was like ooh maybe new
Gordon's up and I was like oh well [__]
me it's not there so um which pissed me
off so I went over to Netflix and I was
like what if they what do they have like
for cooking shows to say to my cooking
show
thing that I wanted to have
so I started watching this show called I
think it's called snack versus Chef have
you guys seen that
so it's all like all these people and
they come on to and they're all like and
they're not you know it's not a show
like um nailed it which actually I kind
of like love that which is just like a
bunch of people that don't really know
what they're doing like it's like here
make this awesome thing and they're just
like ta-da and it's just like really
lame which is funny but it's like I
usually like people that are actually
like competent
so this show is actually like it's all
chefs food scientists
um you know people that are in like
product development like food product
development stuff like that and they
bring them in and they're basically like
okay there's two rounds it's like one
we're gonna have give you a snack it's
like Flamin Hot Cheetos or Oreos or
something like that and you have to
replicate it like they do that first and
then whoever gets the closest like you
know they get they go ahead or whatever
and then they have to do their own snack
food that is kind of like has they can
pretty much do whatever they want but it
has to have to um it has to have like
one of the same
cool things about the random snack that
they picked you know what I mean so it's
like I started watching that last night
and that is like super fun and I didn't
realize I guess I did realize but until
I saw people like making them that [__]
like they had they made them like
replicate Pringles man they had a [__]
of a time doing that and because
Pringles
as delicious as they are
um are not
easy to make well I don't want to say
like potato chips are easy to make but
they're much harder than actual potato
chips because they're not just like
sliced up potatoes that you deep fry
it's paste it's yeah they basically make
a dough they make a dough with
cornstarch and like some other [__] and
potato flakes and then you have to like
press it into the shape and it's like
the people on this show like they didn't
have a mold or anything like that so
they're trying to like replicate the
[__] dough and it was like breaking
or it was like too wet or too dry or
something like that it was like Raptor
said he went to a Korean restaurant up
there to read it up where's the thing
hold on
oh grandpa says uh I ate a high-end
Korean restaurant this week had a hot
pot with pork kimchi Ramen and spam yes
spam it's a national delicacy in Korea
introduced yeah it is um well they eat a
lot of it in Hawaii too Hawaii a lot of
islands I saw a street food like that
shows street food which is also on
Netflix they did a Hawaii one and they
talked about spam on there yeah most
island nations
that deal with the Western that you know
about they have eat a lot of spam
and it's because you know they don't
have cattle there and they were involved
at the U.S military in some way and the
U.S government helped Supply those
islands with meat
and traditionally back in the 50s and
40s and 50s that was spam man that was
an MRE
that's the original MRE
now a granted to you it's a high quality
cut of meat it's pork shoulder it's not
mystery meat all right it was that
recipe was made by a [__] cordon blue
Chef you know the French dude [__]
came up with that [__]
it's a little too Briny the low sodium
versions are a lot easier to eat it's
not very good cold
it's not good eating a block of that
[__] cold out of the soldiers in the
field did it they were desperate and
I've been in that situation when you're
cold and [__] hungry anything tastes
good basically and that would taste real
good when you were [__] starving
um what you do with Spam is you slice it
kind of thin and fry it get it crispy on
the outside
um if it's the high sodium version
you might want to after it's fried
or when you're cooking it try to get
some water in there in the pan and then
throw that water out try to get some of
that salt out of it cook some of the
salt out of it and then once the once
you've thrown that water out
go back to fry it try to get a crisp
back on it or you just offset that that
salt with something that's kind of sweet
if you have it
I like the regular low sodium spam
the flavored spam is real good they even
got chorizo flavored like the Mexican
flavor Mexican sausage flavor that's
good they got everything the flavors the
jalapeno flavor the turkey spam is
pretty good
um have we ever had turkey spam I don't
remember yeah yeah you've had it have I
I don't think I gave it to you I think I
maybe she won't accept spam so I eat it
well even the low sodium spam is too
salty for me
the flavored spam like Teriyaki though
isn't
it was only salty because that recipe
came in a time when salt was one of the
preservatives that they used they
thought they they weren't really sure
how good good canning technology was so
they put a lot of salt in there just in
case yeah
canning technology has been mastered now
if
it's been proven
even with inferior canning technology
100 years ago you can open those cans
and as long as the seal was held you can
eat at right out of that can it's fine a
hundred years
I mean it's probably not delicious but
it's not gonna it's okay yeah
so modern canning technology is a lot
better and the food that they're putting
in there is a lot better and they're
either and then there they added
preservatives on top of that that they
didn't have 100 years ago
it wouldn't surprise me if if a cat is
spam
made today would probably last 150 years
yes the case of zombie apocalypse zombie
apocalypse we're all gonna be fine so
Fallout video game made it not all be
all that inaccurate where they're eating
cram which is Spam well obviously you
don't want to pay the right [__] cramps
and I think the cram was about 200 years
old 300 years old maybe 200 years old
and they were still eating yeah they'd
probably make it yeah it probably
wouldn't hurt you and in the Fallout
Universe they would have irradiated it
sent radiation through it to kill all
the bacteria after the candy process so
that would work too
you know that's some added [__] some
added [__] uh antibacteriological
[__] treatment
send that [__] to the middle of a
nuclear reactor
[Laughter]
uh how is chipped beef on toast Tom good
I'm not a big fan of chip beef on toast
honestly my grandmother used to make it
a lot and um this is y'all are gonna
laugh but I took home ec in junior high
school I think it was seventh grade and
that was one of the things we made [__]
on a shingle that's what my grandpa
called all that [__]
come
all that kind of stuff would fall into
the category of kind of like Southern
food which means soul food
because
Southern whites and blacks ate the same
food
uh when black people move more North
after the Civil War they took a lot of
those foods with them and they kept
moving North too over the decades
and when they took it out of the South
it started to become more like soul food
but the difference between that's what
they would call it the difference
between white southern food and black
southern food was nothing more than the
differences between
a [__] family recipes that's all it
is all right looking they ate the same
food we ate
cornbread greens
[__] the Grits
um
hog jowls or jowls chitlins
you can eat all that we ate pickle pig's
feet and then that went into the pecan
[__] and the [__] that you bought at the
local stores the local grocery stores in
your little neighborhood out in out of
the South somewhere it might even be the
country so that would include Vienna
sausage you know just Spam
man my Dad loved Vienna yeah it is man
oh my dad was big into that [__] too
yeah putting things always had cans I
need to dip them in the mustard salted
peanuts inside Coca-Cola RC Cola it's
another Little Debbie snack cakes just
all that [__] white trash [__] it's
all soul food man
although gonna say like every now and
then we go to Dollar General and get
like a whole bunch of different yeah
yeah and we have some in there now we
got some honey buns and some nutty butt
Nutty Buddies and uh oatmeal cream pies
where we're from the air the region
we're from in the United States the chip
beef on toast we don't really have that
our version of that would be country
gravy on biscuits that's more deluxe if
you ask me but I've had the chip beef on
toes it's not bad [__] on a shingle
that's a little more Northern for us but
if you can learn like I said we made it
at home ec yeah I didn't like it my
Grandma had made it and I was like we
really gotta make that country gravy on
biscuits is much better
which is either hamburger or hamburger
that you turn into beef sausage or pork
sausage or you make your own sausage
crumbles of that and then you take
butter you put it in a pan melt the
butter put um a flour in there and cook
the flour in the butter so it's
basically we're talking about as a light
Roux and then put milk in there to
expand it out so salt and pepper and
then throw those
throw those uh pieces of sausage in
there the sausage crumbles and all the
drippings in other words all the fat mix
it up maybe a dash of red pepper got it
real simple [__] and then pour that over
homemade biscuits
Southerners are [__] NASA you people
in the UK but I don't know what a
biscuit is a biscuit is for us kind of
like us it's just kind of like a scone
it's like a scone but not sweet yeah not
sweet yeah if you explain because the
scone looks essentially the same thing
but scone is usually like a dessert
thing yeah usually have it with um you
know with strawberry jam and clotted
cream which is delicious these are
savory scones but these are like Savory
yeah like you put like meat gravy on
them but a similar kind of thing they're
more like puffy that would look that
would be that's the redneck version of
the dam with some little things that
[__] that that Yorkshire pudding
Yorkshire pudding yeah it's kind of like
that like but I mean Yorkshire pudding
is more like Airy yeah Dairy and puffy
not these These are heavy and bread like
there's a but lay like layers like
there's a good YouTube channel where a
couple British guys go through the
American go through the American South
and they eat all this [__] it's called
jolly that these two dudes there in
there and then there's an american guy
filming them look like a korean-american
guy filming them and they're eating that
southern food and they they love most of
it and biscuits and gravy they [__]
loved it
well they well that's because it's not
that different yeah I mean it sounds
weird at first like to them but then
when they eat it they're like okay I
understand this because it's not that
different from like some yeah some kind
of traditional we had an American
southern Chef who they befriended and
they went out and got loaded and then
afterwards went to Waffle House and they
ordered like [__] nine plates and
between the three of them they all had
it that much those British dudes were
[__] Blown Away by a [__] Waffle
House and he's going the [__] America's
Southern Chef is going on about how
dietetic it is and how low fat of course
fats he's just driving them the whole
time [__] with him
they liked everything except the Grits
[__] they were like he goes oh these
are grits and he goes yeah this is great
he goes he tries and he goes no no those
are bad grits don't eat those just
because it's it is what it is doesn't
mean it's any good grits are good well
grits you guys
yeah you can't just like eat them the
way they are because I mean they're not
terrible but they don't really taste
like much of anything you just kind of
have to do [__] with them you gotta have
cheese and them salt pepper spices it'd
be the same as just like eating a piece
of like white bread with nothing on it
it's just kind of the same thing you
know what I mean you really you gotta
like put some [__] in there but if
you're British or european or anything
like that
Foreigner you want to know what southern
foods like go go on YouTube go look at
look up the channel Jolly
j-o-l-l-y in in all caps and they got
those dudes will review and for the
first time tasting southern food
I gotta tell you though I [__] love
Yorkshire pudding though
God damn that [__] is so good I really
really like the whole British you know
and I don't know how traditional it is
anymore because I know that's my more an
older person thing but I really liked
that whole Sunday dinner thing
with the roast potatoes and the beef and
the gravy and all that it's like that
was like super good I love all that kind
of stuff me and Jenny made a cookbook
that has all those recipes on there yeah
El padrino was asking do you guys have a
good chili recipe and I was gonna say
probably cookbook I think there is a
chili recipe in there I mean we make it
different it's different like Tom makes
it different like depends on what I have
yeah it depends on what we have in the
house
yeah there's a lot of online recipes for
chili
real chili doesn't have any beans in it
it's just all meat okay and man there
was a time when we I would get stew meat
from Sam's it's back when it was more
affordable
and make a huge pot of nothing but just
beef stew meat like Texas style
beef beef stew oh this could be beef
chili
no beans in it at all I think it might
have had onions in it
but I think onion puree might have been
in it so it's almost more like a stew
right yeah it's more like stew because I
kind of feel like a lot of people when
you say chili they just assume there's
beans in it but there's there's kind of
a big controversy over whether chili has
beans in it no it depends on Texas it
does not happen it doesn't have beans in
it usually right beans are a filler I
like beans in them I do too but that's a
sign that you don't have any damn money
I like it either way yeah I like it it
just means you don't have any money
real chili is just beef
in basically Curry it's a it's the same
thing as Indian curry it's just it's a
different amount and it's even many of
the same spices yeah just in different
rates just in different ratios
and uh
you pour it in a bowl next to some
potatoes or rice
and that's you know some people just eat
just that just the chili my grandma used
to put spaghetti in it you could do that
too
I I think it's I don't think it's a
waste though I've had people I've
ordered I've been into some of these
olds back in the day or ordered [__]
spaghetti
and when I when it showed up it was
spaghetti with chili yeah and I was like
that is not spaghetti because that's the
thing that like like I said my grandma
used to do that I knew a lot of people
that used to do that they would make
chili but they would put spaghetti in it
yeah not good I was never like a huge
fan of chili gotta say I mean it's still
not my favorite thing but oh you love
that chili I made yeah it is it is no
I'm just saying that it's not like yeah
you know it's not my super for
everything
and the older I get like the less spicy
stuff I can eat yeah so chili is a Texan
thing and it's
Texas is
the state of Texas was a joint venture
between Rich Mexican families and Rich
North American families they were a
mixture of kind of like the Irish and
the Germans and the Mexicans
and that's who owned that state they
were in there
running the cattle business and
intermarrying
and uh they had
Spanish and Indian Roots mixing with
Western European
and out of that came Texas Chile all
right Texas Chili would be
super popular in Mexico they probably
know about it but uh I'd have to ask
Khan about Salon if he's on there I
would think that Mexico at least on the
border of Texas it probably exists
I don't know if they're doing it right
but I'm pretty confident that if I make
some badass chili and take that [__] to
TJ I'd sell that [__] all day long
they'd probably buy it but like I said
you Mexicans are big into pork
and pork Works in chili
but the proper meat is beef
that's something that's made by cattle
ranchers that's who's coming up with
that [__]
I meant to ask you because I don't think
you watched it with me but I was
watching that series street food yeah
and they did each one was like a
different city like a different Food
City like around the U.S and one of them
was New Orleans yeah and one of the
women that they talked to made what the
[__] was the name of it it was kind of
like a um [__] no I can't remember is it
pastry no no it was um you probably know
ooh Dan no no it wasn't Boudin I would
have remembered that it was like a it's
a noodle thing and it's it's usually for
hangovers I don't know it's a spicy
noodle no I don't know and it's kind of
like a combo and apparently like it's a
it's a New Orleans thing and it's gone
back a long way like maybe probably
somebody in their nose but it was kind
of like a combination between people of
New Orleans and like Chinese okay you
know immigrants
and it was this whole thing and it was
supposed to be like a hangover cure and
this woman like made it and she has a
business now like making it and I wish I
could remember what the name of it was
because I was gonna ask you about it
because I didn't think that I'd heard of
it before but it sounded good it was
kind of well it was similar to like a
Ramen but well tell me what we're
talking about it's kind of yeah it's
like noodles and what the [__] else was
in there it was like some good I mean
the broth was the most important thing
and it was like real spicy
and then there was noodles yeah it was
like a broth and then it had well no I
mean that was the first thing that they
made that was like the most important
aspect noodles with sauce and then it
was noodles they serve it like in a cup
and then there's kind of like meat and
then there was like some other
vegetables in it I can't remember what
all was in there I never heard what was
it called
something Maine or something like that
God damn it I just saw it like a couple
nights ago I never heard of it because I
meant to like call you in because I was
like hey I never heard of this cool I'm
you know on the on the show they're
talking about New Orleans so they
usually would focus on like two or three
different
you know small businesses or somebody
that was like big in the food scene like
in that particular City and then they
would talk about the Specialties of that
particular City so they were talking
about like they had a guy that was like
the Crawfish guy that would do the boils
and all that kind of stuff and so they
had that guy and then they would have
and then they had this lady who was God
damn what the [__] was the name of it
it's like it's on the tip of my tongue
but yeah she
um I don't know I don't think so but
she'd been there like a long time but it
was like her grandmother's recipe and
she would she started out with her and
her son they would make a pot of it and
they just went and they would give it to
um you know the people that would uh
like follow the parades and life she'd
sell it and she would sell out so now
she has like a whole business doing that
I don't know what that is yeah so maybe
somebody's down here it might have been
something real local
I've never heard of that oh [__] I got
like way behind on the [__] yeah
Victor says boudin balls are the best
yeah Boudin right math he's [__] with
me because I eat some boudin balls that
threw the [__] up well that was just
that one time yeah and I couldn't old
sober that's what it's called
that's what it was I knew it was
something mean I couldn't remember thank
you Jeffy what Ming yakamane Yakima oh
they're coming oh it's sober yeah yeah
that's it okay I knew it was something
Maine
and I was like I was like what the [__]
I just saw that like a couple days ago
that's something real specific and real
local that's not real famous
uh well that's what I mean I'd heard of
the other stuff that they talked about
but I'd never heard of that but
apparently that's a very very New
Orleans thing most Cajun foods and New
Orleans based foods really they're not
that old they're coming out of the 1960s
1970s that's Paul perdom he's the one
that made a lot of that stuff famous
uh you know things like black and
catfish and Blackened Redfish and
[__]
etofey pistol a [__] like that you know
it's based on things that were around
before but yeah Jeffy art said it's
popular amongst locals I think yeah
that's kind of what they well they kind
of went in on the show where where they
were like you know everybody knows about
etouffee and gumbo and you know and uh
Beignets and all that kind of stuff but
it's like yakamane is more Boudin is
more like a local yeah thing like that
everybody gets when they're super drunk
yeah yeah Louisiana cooking goes way
back it's just that a lot of the recipes
that they were using were kind of like
imagine how you got to go back to the
40s and 50s and look at Main Street
recipes and see how shitty they were
they were bad ingredients bad
combinations
aspic weird [__] like that whether they
were eating there's a whole Channel
Jenny talks about sometimes with them
trying to do 1950s and old recipes
they didn't have access to to [__]
I mean some of the go look at like
websites like the gallery of regrettable
food which is you will die laughing at
that [__] it's just like hilarious I
think that's mostly goes up to like it's
kind of 50s but it kind of goes up to
the 70s because there was that notorious
set of like Weight Watchers cards that
came out in the 70s which I remember
because my mom had them and like some of
the recipes on there were horrifying and
even like the pictures on there
that's how it was Weight Watchers I
guess because you just looked at the
picture and it's like yeah I'm not
hungry anymore
I'm just I'm just not gonna eat today
because it was just like really
unappetizing most of the Southern dishes
kind of went extinct there were some
things that were consistent that lasted
over time sometimes the day the the the
the disc changed but the names stayed
the same because it was like in honor of
it or an improved version of it but some
things were consistent
fried okra was consistent when somebody
talked about fried okra from their early
1900s they're talking about the same
dish they didn't change it you didn't
have to it was real simple
same thing with hush puppies
Hush Puppies basically were just just
cornmeal you know whatever [__] you had
like water meals deep fry that [__] it's
still like a ball of it and you fry it
in a pan full of [__] Fish Grease I
mean to be because you're cooking
anything anything that you deep fry is
probably gonna be like pretty good yeah
it was just a good hush puppies now late
later on they started doing things like
adding corn niblets to it and pieces I
kind of like it with the corn nipples
yeah yeah it's good I mean there's a
plain too but it's like they're good
with like the corn nipples and they
start adding they start making sauces to
dip them in you know vinegar based
sausage or sauces kind of like [__]
remoulade which is like a mustardy kind
of mayo type of thing
um
what else was consistent Fried Chicken
was pretty consistent over the years
um fried catfish very consistent it's
just corn cornmeal
catfish rolled in corn salted salted and
seasoned cornmeal fried that's it
um
trying to see what else was [__]
consistent Boudin was probably pretty
consistent because it was always bad
[Laughter]
damn fried baseball of internal organs
with [__] hey gotta use that [__]
somehow
sorry I want to like say uh ish Khan
said I watched your Jack Parsons show
now here okay well this is absolutely
nothing like the Jack Parsons no no
we're just getting you all ready to
party we're talking talking your way
this is our Sidetrack show where we just
talk about whatever usually food I'm
talking about the situation where you
all are done for the work week getting
ready for the weekend and we're gonna
launch you into the Stars so you can be
up there with the stars and the UFOs and
the outer planets
okay so you linked it together oh yeah
Stars UFOs out of planets ghosts all
that [__] up in the Heavenly Realms okay
with the scientologists
going across in the morning across the
bridge
yeah or whatever the hell that planet is
that's right [__] Z news coming down
with his [__] DC nines dropping a
Time
dropping atomic bombs on the volcanoes
and we're not even making that up
Senor stick says Tom how were the MRE
cigarettes back in the day didn't have
cigarettes in the MREs when I was in
yeah that was a little bit because you
were in the 90s right yeah that was a
little bit cigarettes that's World War
II and Korea
here they were normal cigarettes they uh
I think they were [__] camels and
Paul balls and [__] Marlboros I think
I don't even think they were filtered I
think they were filterless back in back
in that era yeah I did the cigarette
filters that was like a later uh
invention was it not yeah they were just
kind of like yeah I get lung cancer as
quickly as possible
didn't matter man it didn't matter those
dudes didn't didn't have a long life
expectancy
people yeah they were like what whatever
yeah
people
people look what most people know of
[__] combat and warfare
in this generation
they get from Hollywood movies and video
games they think you go to war
execute missions shoot a bunch of dude
and then it's over you win and you come
home no you go to war and guess what
happens you die
all right most of those dudes that went
went after World War II died all right
they were [__] killed a couple times
over depending on what what side you
were on Russia lost its Army about five
times and over you know I think they
figured I saw the casualties and it was
just mind-boggling casualties
you know in the Millions
you know you're if you were a German
your chances of surviving the war was
[__] next to zero
a German fought on the front lines in
that war until he died
yeah at the end it was nothing but old
men and little kids fighting
okay so that's what it's really like
recently you know
past 1950 Korea was the last real kind
of War we were in and anything after
that was basically kind of like a a
police action
half ass
[__] law enforcement type situation
real war is genocide you're just [__]
trying to get around the enemy Army to
bomb the women and children sleeping in
their beds at night and burning down
whole cities and attacking their [__]
infrastructure and trying to topple
their religions and you're trying to
erase them from the earth and the last
time that happened was World War II but
that's the way it really is it's the way
it was going back to [__] the Old
Testament you know
because you don't want any of them to
survive they'll come back
they'll come back and get Vengeance on
you
which you're going to see now the whole
world's turned against us for all the
[__] we've been doing the past 70
years
they're all ganging up
with Russia because Russia is going to
offer them some [__]
but our banking cartels have [__] over
these people so badly and [__] all
the [__] we did in Central and South
America over the past hundred and
something years they're sick of us I
don't blame them I'm sick of them too
went a long way from the cigarette
question dude yeah yeah yeah yeah
I do what I want to do let me go to the
restroom Zach says best or favorite
Seafood
um all of it yeah it's all good honestly
I like all Seafood
um
I don't know
I don't know if I could pick
pretty much anything that well I don't
want to say anything that comes out of
the ocean because that's a little
General but most things that come out of
the ocean all at least eat it
I love Seafood
and Tom Sykes said camels are the best I
don't think I ever smoked camels I did
smoke for a while
um
I mostly smoked Pall Malls
but you know whatever Camp guy said I
started watching that Mormon documentary
on Netflix wasn't that [__] up that
it's it made me so angry I couldn't
believe how many children those folks
had with two or three wives 40 or 50
kids all half brothers and sisters
that's what yeah we were watching that
[__] and I was like God these poor
[__] women it's like their [__]
vaginas are like [__] clown cars man
God
I don't know it just uh
it grossed me out it grows me out like
the whole thing just cursed me out
yeah no wonder they have to keep like
accurate accurate genealogy records yeah
exactly it's like well we have to keep
track of like [__]
whose moms like all these [__] it's
just like one [__] like fathered
all of these 60 ass people
ugh
I just I don't know
I don't get it man
I don't get it like I said if you're an
adult and you want to join something
like I don't know why you would but okay
people are different
um but man raising your kids and that
kind of thing that's a whole different
[__] situation man
whole different situation
ish kind of said is this about cooking
it's about anything I mean the Sidetrack
show we initially I don't know if you
know but we initially started this as an
incentive for not going off on Side
Tracks on our main show uh but obviously
that did not work because we still do
that [__] but this show is actually this
is our fun one we do this on Friday
every Friday night where we just
drink and talk about whatever whatever
comes up so
how's shark meat
it's um it's pretty good it's not super
strong
I've only had it once or twice in my
entire life but it's not like super
fishy tasting like it's pretty
I don't know I remember it being like
pretty firm it's good but it's not like
real fishy tasting you know what I mean
uh let's see Senor stick says Jenny you
can order vintage MREs some with
cigarettes and canned coffee oh that's
kind of neat like wait are they from
back then
or are they just made to
like resemble which is from back then
vintage MREs with cigarettes and canned
coffee in them
I'll talk about
it well there's that channel on YouTube
I guess it's still around I can't
remember what it's called Tom probably
knows but that guy like he has he gets
MREs like from
you know World War II world like I think
he even had some World War One ones but
like he'll open them and eat the stuff
out of them hahaha
I'm gonna ask Tom because he's the one
that that channel where that guy eats
stuff out of old MREs what's that
channel called is it still around yeah
it's still around you don't get [__]
from [__] world war one that's what
I'm saying I thought let me straighten
some [__] out first of all
the MRE was the meal ready to eat if I'm
correct if memory serves that was 1980s
there were no MREs prior to that
um each aricon had their own ration and
its own name for it
the Vietnam era which they may have had
cigarettes in those maybe that would
have been the C ration I believe yeah
I'm pretty sure that's what they got
yeah and I mean it's the same thing they
just called it no there's a difference
well similar there's a difference
um the MRE
did not come in cans they were metal
flat bags which makes a big difference
in the field
the way that's stacked
and the way you cook that all right you
have to get that out of that MRE and
cook it in the old days you had to cook
it in a canteen cup with a [__]
little bit of Sterno solid Sterno fuel
comes I got a bunch of them I can show
you what it what it looks like there's a
little holder
underneath your canteen cup there was
another outer sleeve you could take it
off turn it upside down like that it had
holes in it you could put a bit of
Sterno underneath there and cook inside
that cup
they also gave you a
a mess kit which I have one out here
that I use for our electric stove
for our break room
and you can cook in that too but that
was tended to be bulky
and kind of getting ahead of myself
I was
in an Airborne infantry and aerosol
infantry units and it was also in a
Recon platoon
four years
and you had to be highly mobile your
rucksack wasn't with you all the time so
you usually had to cook out of your lce
which was a [__] battle built with
suspenders that's you guys would know it
today
so you have to carry your food and all
your cooking equipment and your sleeping
equipment and your first aid and all
your ammo and your water
all on that belt
so you're not the
you have a Pack but you might be
separated from that pack for several
days if you've cashed it and you're
going out you're doing patrols and doing
other things
having a cans under those conditions
is a [__] [__] because they're big
they're hard they're odd shaped you
can't they're not they they're difficult
to stack and pack inside a thing called
a butt pack which is a [__] pack on
the back of your belt the smaller your
waist
and you also got your damn tent in there
well we call it a tent it wasn't really
a tent we call it a hooch
which was a apacho liner a poncho excuse
me uh that has rings in it metal rings
and you we take bungee cord you stretch
it out amongst trees and pull the top up
you need five bungee cords and you can
make a little tent and go underneath
there
and keep the rain off you and cook
um
so cans are a lot harder
they weren't that heavy people well the
cans are heavy no not really if you have
an empty can in the empty bag there
wasn't a big difference
it's just that the shape of them was
inconvenient it was hard to stack them
and they're carrying the Alice carrying
equipment that we used
so what was his question I'm not losing
track
after all that yeah yeah
it's just okay the MRE is not very old
that's like 80s
the rest of it was [__] like sea rations
but you don't remember what the name of
that channel was where that guy just
like eats the stuff from because that's
actually really interesting like he gets
I don't know where he gets him from like
probably like eBay or people send him
stuff or people send them to him and
it's like some of them are yeah some of
them are super old like some of them
were for World War one and stuff before
yeah he had some stuff from the 1800s
and he's just like I'm just like you're
braver than me man yeah and it'd be like
a can and you use a can opener to open
it and in there would be like a couple
other packets a pack of round cracker
with some coffee and some a packet of
sugar or a packet of tea or something
like that
and uh maybe like some
cheese spread
and he'd try to eat that and it mostly
he he said mostly the lack flavor or
you know yeah I can imagine tasted kind
of stale but I mean he's still alive
presumably so I guess nothing's killed
him yeah some of that stuff was over 100
years old
and as long as the seal is have broken
on them
it's edible
yeah I mean technically theoretically if
something is canned and the can isn't
damaged
I mean it might not taste great but it's
probably not going to kill you it'll
give you some nutrition anyway the can
didn't have to be damaged though it's
because the the technologies that they
use changed over time sometimes they
soldered the lids onto them using
different kinds of solder that would
sometimes contaminate that what was in
there
and other times they would try to the
solder job wasn't complete there was an
empty space there
you know which allowed over time
uh contamination to work its way in yeah
you don't want air so yeah
so
every time he opened something he had to
really inspect things to make sure that
it had not yeah I was trying to be
scared too yeah I mean other than the
fact that it probably doesn't taste very
good
well some of me opened and it was
nothing but just tried up ball of black
grease and you know right there that
that
the the seal was broken it's like yeah
we're not we're not going to eat that
yeah it would be like a black look like
a black tar and at one time it was it
was considered to be like stew
but it just looks like a little bullax
ball like clearly not stewing yeah uh
yeah ishkan says botulism is just used
as Botox now yeah pretty much
pretty much
[Laughter]
I don't know City senior sticks is
talking about canned bread yeah you know
I don't know if you can buy that because
I thought that was more like a northern
and Canadian thing
have you seen that like it's brown bread
it's it's not Pumpernickel is it
and it can be it's like a dark brown but
that's the one the most common one that
I've seen yeah but I don't know if I've
ever seen that in the grocery store not
that I've looked for it but I don't
think we have it down here no but I
thought that was mostly like an up north
or like a Canadian militaries have used
that kind of stuff yeah yeah I've seen
it just not interested about that big
and about that high and you'd [__]
take the top of it off and there's a
little cake of bread in there that you
just slice in half and put something in
there make like a sandwich out of it
it's [__] you know it always tastes the
texture well the ones that I've seen
that they sell in the grocery stores
apparently in New England and in Canada
are like you know the Dole pineapple
juice can yeah like that size yeah yeah
and there's like a loaf of bread it's
usually like real dark brown bread like
Pumpernickel that's basically what I
said though yeah yeah yeah well I
thought you said it was like a smaller
no that's big about that big yeah so
it's like a like a Dole pineapple juice
yeah a little bit bigger than a double
pineapple can but about that same the
same proportions the ones that I saw now
they gave us MRE bread which is just in
a brown bag bag about this big
and it was kind of like a little loaf of
bread that was smashed down kind of what
it was like kind of heavy it was just
white bread
and no matter what you put on it you
never really had that light fluffy
Wonder Bread kind of flavor that's not
what it was but that I like denser bread
though yeah it was kind of like Wonder
Bread had been smashed down and it was a
little bit dry
because it had to have a long shelf life
but we put the cheese
squeeze cheese it would come out of that
bag on it or we they also gave us peanut
butter jelly in two different containers
two different kinds of jelly had grape
jelly you had Apple
and you'd make peanut butter and jelly
sandwiches and a few British people
that's peanut butter jam
and if you had two pieces I never really
could I thought two pieces was too much
and the way the texture was when you
started biting it all split out the
sides it was better to just put it on
the top eat it like that I just said
like open face yeah yeah and and you if
if you had two pieces of bread you were
[__] super full by the time you got
rid of done with that sandwich and it's
only the size of a graham cracker but
it's about an inch thick each loaf like
I said I like dense bread [__] would
fill you up man I kind of feel like that
one of the things that I noticed that
when I lived in the UK like that people
that have been to the United States one
of the things they complained about was
that if you just buy bread off the shelf
just like Marita or wonder bread or
whatever that it tasted like cake
because there's a lot of sugar in it
whereas in uh Europe and stuff like that
the bread is like not as sweet so the
bread bread is like very sweet to them
another thing they do over there is like
their bread is much denser which uh or I
guess it depends on the kind of bread
which I actually like much better
I like real I like a real hearty bread I
don't like uh Pumpernickel or rye as
much but I do like
uh multi-grain Breads and like breads
that are like really really dense you
know what I mean Zach says he doesn't
know why European people get so upset
about peanut butter I'll tell you what
European peanut butter what they were
what they traditionally were getting
access to sucked
yeah so it was understandable that
because what they were getting and was
perceiving as peanut butter was not the
same thing that we were getting the
Americans have gone down there and
gotten say like British peanut butter
and they were like this is not peanut
butter they'd [__] throw that [__]
out it's like that shit's gross I
mentioned it one time and we had a
German listener and she just became a
peanut butter fanatic wanting to know
what yeah where she been I don't know
where are you Sandra yes she's just
getting Skippy and Peter Pan and all
this is good good brands
okay I love peanut butter yeah but
that's not evidently I have a jar of
peanut butter right there matter of fact
yeah that's not evidently what yeah and
this and this is that's just dollars
that's still great that's Dollar General
peanut butter I just got that because I
got some wheat bread and I was like oh
I'll make some toast and I'll put that
[__] on it and it's still it was a buck
yeah
so we got good we got our peanut butter
is much better here than than what was
it traditionally available in in Europe
um now they can get the good [__] but
they gotta look for it they gotta ask
for it
I think I think Sandy Sandra had to
order it
and um
but that wasn't their traditional brands
that they had laying around
but evidently the texture is wrong uh
it's it tastes very artificial it's not
really
what an American would consider peanut
butter to be
I mean peanut butter is delicious and
the thing about it is like it's not just
an American thing because like Thai food
uses a lot of like peanut sauces so like
peanut butter and stuff yeah but that
might be Thai American though I don't
know if they have that actually in
Thailand same way as Chinese food here
it's not really Chinese yeah maybe
that's what I mean I didn't think it was
a specifically and the thing about it
too is that nowadays yeah which is oh my
God that's one of the best things ever
that peanut sauce that they do yeah oh
my God hasn't made that a long time we
make that yeah oh yeah we haven't made
that in a long time God damn you made
that like a couple years back and I was
like oh my God that [__] was like
[__] orgasmic that [__] was so good
but like that's the thing like we don't
just have you don't just have peanut
butter we have all different nut Butters
now yeah yeah almond butter and cashew
butter and stuff like that which I
honestly I really like cashew butter but
that shit's like eight dollars a jar so
yeah I don't buy it that often but it's
like it's delicious though
uh ish Khan says warm toast and peanut
butter is pretty clutch yeah yeah I mean
on real butter on one side well and
that's why I don't even have to put
butter on I like butter on it too I mean
butter on it is good too but to be
honest I just went over to like I said I
went over to Dollar General I got a
toaster we got a toaster oven for
Christmas yeah to put up here like so we
our lazy asses didn't have to go
downstairs and uh you know so I just I
got a whole loaf of wheat bread and a
little jar of peanut butter take two
pieces of white bread toast put butter
on one side butter on the other side of
the bread peanut butter on that side
with the butter and Nutella on the other
side with that butter and put it
together make a sandwich that is also
good hell yeah that is awesome good yeah
with coffee yeah
I mean Simple Pleasures man yeah you
gotta like take
gotta take the Simple Pleasures we can
get them
like I said you know
uh ish Khan said Almond Joys have nuts
Mounds don't I mean both of them are
good but honestly if you're going for
candy bar like and I love Mounds but
Almond Joy is way better fight me I like
them both they're both good they're both
taking Almond Joy well now mountains is
dark chocolate is it not I think it is
but I think it's dark whereas Almond Joy
is milk chocolate I'll take either one
but I kind of like the Almond Joys
better I do too okay uh do you guys have
any questions you want to talk about any
topics anything paranormal or True Crime
you can just go ahead and drop it down
in the comment section and we can start
taking it that way if not we're gonna
sit around talk about food getting it
getting fat how long we've been how long
we've been doing the show one hour 151
minutes almost two hours actually so
there's not really that much time left
on the ship
Zach says I really love the Breakfast
Crunchwrap from Taco Bell but I always
feel like I need a triple bypass after
eating them I don't know that I don't
think I've ever heard of it but I don't
think I've ever I don't eat at Taco Bell
a lot
so I mean I don't even know where the
closest Taco Bell is to here honestly
I'm sure there is one but I don't know
um and I know that they have breakfast
stuff and I know that a lot of people
like those but I don't think I've ever
had one so
Victor said was there a Parsons show I
love that dude yeah we did a show about
Jack Parsons when the [__] was that a
year ago yeah a long time ago yeah I
think so it was a long time it was when
we were in this house I'm pretty sure
yeah so I think oh [__] now I don't even
remember and we've only lived here for
like a year and a half so
yeah Camp guy said uh they grow some of
the best peanuts in the world in Georgia
I believe they lead the nation in peanut
butter yeah that's what I always heard
okay uh Petrino says that he's finally
made his appointment for [__] HRT
you're gonna love it bro you're gonna
love it
um it's good that you go through a uh uh
legitimate HRT clinic first
let them give you your basic training so
you know how to [__] use all that
what what
what it feels like and what they're
going to give you and then later on man
after about six months you can [__]
Dodge it they're probably gonna have you
on some kind of contract where you got
to be with them for a certain amount of
time and give them a certain amount of
notice before they pull you off the
program and if you go off too early
they're going to send you your last
[__] shipment of drugs anyway but
once
once you really know your ropes
there are other ways to get that those
substances for you know
testosterone HCG you can get all that
stuff a lot cheaper from other sources
and the quality is [__] as good or
better
but
I'm glad that I went I started off as a
at a clinic because I would I have more
I was being assured that I was getting
good quality stuff and that what I was
going through was normal okay because
it's going to be like an adjustment
period Well you need a baseline I've got
to have a baseline to know what's normal
yeah right
um and under medical supervision all
that different until the beginning of
like week three the first couple weeks
you're like yeah I feel like a slight
relief but it's not it's kind of weak
and then
week week three hits you and you're like
oh okay this is what they're talking
about yeah okay yeah you'll see
Oscar asked me if I had seen skinamarink
yet I have not but I'm really looking
forward to that that's probably my most
anticipated horror movie from this year
and I'm seeing I see like because I'm
subscribed to a lot of horror movie
channels so I'm looking at people's I
haven't watched any videos but I see
their little cards and like their little
reaction faces and stuff and it seems
like it's getting
my favorite kind of reaction which is
like some people are like oh my God this
is the best movie ever and like the
other half of the reaction to like what
the [__] did I just watch and I was just
like those are usually the best kind of
movies and those are usually what I like
the most so we'll see but I that's like
my most anticipated so I definitely will
see it uh sooner rather than later
Victor said he's also on it he's doing
his Telehealth [__] next week so you
haven't actually started it or uh that's
when you're gonna start it
you haven't started your first uh
[__] serious objections done yet
Tom Sykes also talking about another
horror movie called super host yeah I've
heard that one was good too that's on
shutter right
so yeah I'll get around to watching that
one eventually too Black Adam is now I'm
still behind yeah I heard it's great
yeah we'll have to like watch that one
is Shazam in it
oh I don't know
like I said I don't like to watch movie
reviews before I don't even like to
watch trailers all right you know what I
mean yeah
um sometimes I'll like accidentally like
I said I'll see people's like reactions
because you know how everybody likes to
do those uh thumbnails where they're
like like they're making faces and stuff
and I'm just like okay so I'll see that
like in my stream
so I was like okay I get an idea of like
how people are reacting to some stuff
but I don't really like to I don't like
to watch trailers I don't like to watch
reviews nothing until I've seen a movie
I just like to come at it
with as little preconceptions as
possible
you know Oscar's asking me how do I
blast calves for for maximum size
um a lot of that has to do with genetics
I didn't even [__] work any of mine
out man I got better calves than half
your [__] ifbb Pros uh and I think it
might have had something to do with
muscle memory me being in the Army doing
a lot of that [__] rock marching
early on with all that weight on my back
as soon as I started going on [__] my
[__] calves just boom I could show it
to [__] dudes they're huge and they
go oh man yeah you got a [__] good
cat so genetics may be part of it or
early upbringing if you were doing heavy
work early when you were young and then
you go on any kind of anabolic so
[__] if it was legwork
that [__] will [__] enhance
um let's say you're on something test
or any kind of other anabolics and
you're you've been on it for about a
year or so and your calves don't really
look all that good
you probably have to do something like
do squats and then on the upstairs of
the squats try to go up onto your
tiptoes and the last [__] something
like that
something to work the calves
um and
there's only so much you can do with
calves based on what I'm saying
I mean there are some people's genetics
has a lot to do with it the African
genetics are do not have big calves they
got those people got small calves even
the ifbb pros that [__] weigh 200
something pounds in relation to the rest
of their body mass their calves are
still usually not all times but usually
still a little bit smaller in
proportions it's just that's the way
African genetics are
if you're Hispanic
I don't really know what Indian Mexican
Indian style DNA is like when it comes
to to calves but let's say you might
have some European
DNA in youth that might help the
Europeans have big calves but so the
Koreans it just depends
depends depends on what kind of what
your Gene what your genetics are like
some things you just can't fix well I'll
say a fix in in quotations certain looks
you just can't achieve no matter what
what your genetics are like white guys
are going to look like white guys for
the most part
black guys are going to look like black
guys that's just the way we're built
Sly says uh M night's new movie knock at
the cabin door uh yeah okay now I did
see the trailer for that one and the
reason that I saw the trailer for that
one was because I hadn't realized I
don't know if you know but that is based
on a novel called the cabin at the End
of the World by Paul Tremblay which
actually I really really liked I
reviewed it probably a year or two ago
that novel and I didn't know that they
had made a movie adaptation of it so I
so I was like oh my God I'm curious
about that so I did watch the trailer
the trailer looks good but because it's
M Night Shyamalan I'm
torn about it like it could be great or
it could be or it could suck really hard
because I really liked that book I liked
that book a lot and matter of fact I
liked that book better than Paul
tremblay's other book which everybody
loves which was head full of ghosts
which was also awesome but I liked had I
liked uh cabin at the end of the world a
little bit better but
I don't know
I don't know we'll see how it goes I'm
interested to see it because I did
really really like the book and the
trailer looked good it looked like it
was pretty close
to the novel but
I know how M night does so we'll see I'm
I'm maintaining like um
from my experience
watching shambling stuff
he has one of the best superhero [__]
trilogies I'm gonna say maybe even the
one that I see ghosts that may have been
in that same universe I think he he has
one of the best or whatever sixth sense
I think that might still be in there
with it I mean that's still his best
movie which I hate to say because it was
like his first one but I think I think
that other Trilogy with the damn
superheroes I think is one of the best
original superhero tales ever
but can I I love uh I think I have all
three of them don't I or I have two do I
have all three oh wait do you have I
think I only have the fruit do I have
those
I don't know I wanted to buy it I gotta
you have a [__] ton of I got a [__] I
don't think you have six cents though I
don't have I don't have six well you
don't have six cents but you might have
the other glass and shattered and
they're called glass no what's it called
well glass is one of them glass and
splits this one yeah and what was the
other what was the last one uh
unbreakable Unbreakable yeah they were
[__] great
and I I thought they were just up there
with like some Marvel or DC would do and
they were low budget but they didn't
have to be they didn't have to be high
budget a good storytelling
so he so shamlin's he is great
but I think he's great with more
original material
his original [__] I think well that's
why I'm kind of like I don't know I'm I
feel ambivalent about this whole because
I really really liked the novel that
this movie was based on I liked I have
it it's like over there on my bookshelf
but
I mean it's a great idea for a story it
seems like it's right in his wheelhouse
so he might do it justice I don't know
we'll see how it goes some of the stuff
that he made I didn't think it was any
good like signs
a lot of people like science but I don't
like it I don't love it yeah good acting
though and it but it didn't quite
deliver you know [__] um but like I
said it it was a low budget movie like
I'm not gonna [__] on people that like
Signs it is a good movie I'm not saying
that but it's like I think it's just me
because I'm not like a real big ooh
scary aliens I don't like find aliens
Gary not usually like other than you
know Alien aliens like the Ridley Scott
movies that's scary but like other than
that not so much so anything that has to
do with like aliens come to Earth and
ooh that's like the big bad it's just
like meh if you have not seen his
basically his superhero Trilogy of
realistic superheroes what would a
superhero actually be like you know if
they existed it I think it's just great
because they didn't have suits or
anything like that they were just people
that had weird abilities
and they didn't know anything about they
didn't know why they had these abilities
I thought that was a [__] and then
one dude was a [__] crazy ass serial
killer with multiple personality
disorders and he's a super villain
and Mr glass was a super villain I just
thought that was great storytelling and
I thought I loved those movies I I
better I gotta go in there and check and
see if I have them I think I only have
the first two
yeah I don't remember which one I think
I got the first two I don't didn't have
that third one
Zach says did you see the trailer for
Ari astra's new movie yet I haven't but
I did see the trailer for Brandon
Cronenberg has a new movie coming out
which I'm also very excited about it's
called infinity pool and uh yeah that
also looks bird of [__] if you haven't
seen Brandon cronenberg's other movies
he's made two so far one was called
antiviral and one was called what was
the other one called we just saw it
possessor possessor uh yeah that was
great and that had the chick from uh
that was uh she was in Mandy she was in
that too
Andrea reisborough I think her name is
um but yeah those two were great I mean
Brandon Cronenberg he's I mean his stuff
is very is
in the same ballpark as his dad's but
he's kind of got his own spin on it you
know and I think that's kind of cool so
I saw the trailer for infinity pool
which is his new one and that actually
looks pretty cool too so I'm looking
forward to that too but like I said
Skinnamarink is my actually uh that's
kind of my most anticipated that's
Canadian is it not I think it's Canadian
that movie
Victor says signs was good The Happening
was dumb lady in the water was dumb
those two I kind of like I they looked
dumb just from the trailers and I will
admit that I have not had the patience
to sit down and like sit through them
didn't he do the one where they had the
people they were in that in that cult
and you didn't know what year it was the
village The Village yeah didn't he do
that one yeah that one was pretty good
it was all right it's pretty good you
know what um I saw that in the theater
when it came out and I didn't love it
I liked it a little bit better the
second time around I still didn't love
it but it was better than when I saw it
the first time when shamlin came out man
he was a breath of fresh air he would he
could come up with some new [__]
but he got hooked on the twist thing for
a while if he doesn't do that anymore
which I think that's a good thing uh but
I think he's a good filmmaker I think
he's good uh yeah at his his superhero
Trilogy uh uh Sly was saying the same
thing he thought they were Marvel or DC
type stories
um but his superheroes were [__]
great
great if I can
you can make a TV mini-series on that
which that's saying something today
isn't it back in the day you know TV
mini series but no I would have loved I
would have loved to have seen more of
that I want more of that
even though they got killed
it was like the end of it
well that's kind of one of the things
that's cool about nowadays is because I
know a lot of people piss and moan about
oh it's like there's so much there's so
many streaming services and stuff but in
a way that's good because you can
see all like they can make a series for
like some streaming service over here
like from some book that you love and
you like able to see it I remember how I
said a while back how I was like oh I
wonder how they haven't made and Royce's
like uh the witch thing the major
witches yeah into a series they did okay
uh I think AMC made it because I noticed
I was on shutter last night and they
actually put the first episode up there
for free just like they did with
Interview with the Vampire so it's like
oh eventually I gotta watch that because
I actually did like the Mayfair witches
book Zach says M night is making a bit
of a comeback at the moment I binged his
show servant recently and it's really
good I think you'd like that show too
Jenny oh so it's a series yeah servant
yeah sounds familiar I think I saw I
think I saw what services is it on
because we have most of them I have
shutter I have Hulu I have Amazon Prime
I have HBO Max I have
uh what else do we have Netflix
obviously
a lot of different ones we have a lot of
different ones he had a couple bomb
movies but that doesn't Prejudice me
against him I'll watch what he makes
I've mostly been satisfied and like I
said those three those three movies in
that that fourth one [__] with the
kid that could see the dead people think
I thought those were all masterpieces
when he's on he's on
yeah yeah I think like I said I hate to
pick on M night but I think what
happened with him was that he came out
in his first movie his first big movie
was the sixth sense which was so good
that put the bar High yeah and it's like
then after that what are you gonna do
after that it was just kind of like you
know he come in and it's like hey this
is like an awesome movie and then like
the everyone you make after that I was
like man I wasn't as good as your first
one you know what I mean so
there's something to be said for kind of
coming out and making a movie that's
like good but not fantastic so then you
have like some room to like improve
although I will and I've mentioned this
before
uh I will complain once again about when
this The Sixth Sense came out like which
is a good movie I'm not saying that
but it came out almost the same time as
Stir of Echoes the movie that was based
on the Richard Matheson Novella which in
my opinion was a better movie
I saw both of them in the theater back
in when did that come out 1999
I want to say it was 19.99. so I saw
both of them in the theater probably
within like a week of each other
and I liked them both but I was really I
was always really bitter about the sixth
sense because it seemed to like take a
lot of attention away from Stir of
Echoes because a lot of people didn't
hear about it even though it's awesome
it's quite a bit different than the book
I might have made a video over on my
other channel like comparing the two I
don't remember if I did or not but I was
going to I don't remember if I did or
not but um yeah it's a lot different
than the book but it's still good like
both of them are so good but if you
haven't seen stir Becca see Star
Rebecca's with Kevin Bacon
um yeah 19.99 that's what I thought I
think it's on Apple okay I don't have
that I don't have that so maybe that's
why I haven't like seen it but
I mean I don't know like I said I still
got oh my God I have like so many
[__] things to watch I'm so behind
I'm so behind
just today if any of you are following
the [__] over on my scare Salon
yeah it's gonna be a long show tonight
huh yeah okay I mean whatever we're not
going anyplace
[Laughter]
we're not going anyplace so might as
well
um I've been re-watching the Thriller
series with Boris Karloff from the early
1960s and I've been doing like six
episodes at a time and every now and
then like putting a video up like
talking about them so just today I
finished the next watching the next six
episodes and I almost have like the
review like completely entirely done so
I'll probably record it tomorrow I might
put it up tomorrow too if I get it
edited in time but we'll see but yeah
I'm having a good time with those that's
like a really good series
um Jenny have you done a show oops I'm
popped up in front of my chat okay
have you done a show on Robert Hansen
that dude killed over 15 girls from the
70s and 80s in Alaska I don't remember
if we did although that name is very
familiar
so I'll have to check
because I kind of forget
which ones we've done and which one we
haven't you know what I mean
best movie in 1999 was American Pie
laughs
I'm not a big fan of comedies I don't
know why I don't know what it is I just
honestly I could probably count on one
hand maybe two hands like the number of
comedies that I like
I don't I don't know I have just like a
really weird like um
idiosyncratic sense of humor so it's
like a lot of things that I watch and I
was like that's not really that funny
but then like a lot of things that
aren't supposed to be funny or funny to
me so you know it's kind of like hard
for me to
get into
Zach says uh man 99 was a great year for
movies my favorite from that year was
The Talented Mr Ripley yeah I remember
that being pretty decent I think I might
have said not in the theater too because
the thing about it was that in 1999
I still lived in Daytona Beach at that
point
and me and my best friend I mean we were
out of high school and we were out of
college too at that time
you know so we were like both working
but we used to go there was I don't
think it's there anymore but there used
to be a dollar theater in Daytona Beach
so you'd get like all the second run
movies but you could go see them for a
buck so a lot of times if we weren't
like going renting movies we would go to
the theater and see like sometimes we'd
see like a couple of them a night like
we'd go and pay a dollar and go see this
one and go pay a dollar and go see that
other one and so we saw pretty much
everything that came out like as long as
it sounded interesting I did like I said
I didn't usually go see comedies or
anything like that we usually Saw horror
movies or Thrillers or weird Indie
movies and [__] like because that's what
we were into but like yeah we saw like
pretty much everything that's why during
the 90s like every time it's like oh I
think I saw that in the theater I saw
pretty much everything at the theater
back then because it was a dollar you
know what I mean you had to wait like a
month uh you know because it was all
second run but you know if you if you
could wait if you weren't all that
excited about seeing it you could see a
robot
Zach says someday one movie I'd love to
make is some kind of dark comedy about
autistic adults just because so many
stories about people like me are sad or
real sappy and I'd like to see something
different well that's the thing I kind
of do feel like
I always find it's very interesting yeah
because the thing about it is that if
somebody has
I don't know if somebody has some kind
of I don't want to call it a condition
or something like that but if you have
something like about you that's
different it's almost like maybe this is
changing now but back in the old days
it's like well we have to make the whole
movie about their struggle with this
thing and it's like why can't they just
be like a person that has that and
that's maybe like a subplot or it's like
something to do but it's not like the
main thing like we're not you know it's
like not like this big weepy thing where
we're just like oh my God she has cancer
or oh my God she has autism or oh my God
she has like some other thing you know
what I mean oh my God she's a little
person or something it's like can we
just not make the whole movie about that
oh they're running out of [__] to make
movies about
well I don't know see that's the thing I
don't think you'll ever run out of [__]
to make movies man they came up with
crazy [__] turbo kid it was a was a
turbo kid
was a superhero movie in a
post-apocalyptic world that was a great
movie that's a great idea it was a
French movie I think it's on um great
movie at the moment I think I have that
one don't I you might I might I go and
look at that that's one of money to get
one of my favorite movies nice movie
and it's I'm gonna run to the bathroom
okay there's oh commercials well you got
to do it I'm gonna do the commercial
okay well I'm kind of laughing at you
because I didn't realize this yeah okay
I gotta tell you guys this because I
really have to pay so I didn't notice
because I don't usually watch the live
streams like back over again
but somebody commented on the show that
we did on Wednesday they're like the
funniest part of this show was that some
of the commercials were on yeah and then
it went to the where's that raccoon yeah
I did that yeah and then there was like
a couple seconds of you looking
thoughtful yeah and then the other girl
yeah yeah yeah and everybody yeah yeah
and I think the guy well it was like a
newer I guess it was like a newer person
and I guess they didn't know what the
words that raccoon thing was it was like
I didn't realize that you would like
inserted the where's that raccoon yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah situation you know
somebody somebody in the in the comments
said yeah I put the record yeah it's
like well it's even half because I use
OBX or OBS rather
so it's like I don't say you have like a
little list over here of like scenes
what they call it so I name everything
so yeah I do have one that says where is
that raccoon so if you click on that
it'll show like the words I reckon all
right go ahead go ahead and do I can't
see it I don't have my glasses on go
ahead and do the first one well you
really need glasses these are reading
glasses I can't see all that see these
women trying to tell me what to do I got
reading glasses
God damn dude I still don't have man
said I could I really need it he doesn't
quite say man said I could that's the
problem
man said it was okay that's all he said
he says man well okay he says man said I
don't have to listen to you yeah I
remember him saying that yeah and then
he says man says his man says okay man
said it was okay yeah yeah I think
that's maybe I could find him doing that
right all right all right so here's some
commercials I'm gonna run to the
bathroom
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
all right here we are Jaguar hard Jaguar
must be he's got to be the kind of Asana
probably but I was I don't know if you
were listening earlier my question was
is does Mexico have Texas style chili
where it's just beef there's no beans in
it or anything it's just beef in that
damn sauce because that's like stew type
beef cubes of it I didn't know if they
had that in Mexico I would think that
that would sell real well in Mexico
Texas Chili
yeah you think I'm gonna think so that's
another good show on Netflix by the way
it's called what is it called the taco
Chronicles
yes remember that it's like a
documentary Series yeah because that
like I said we're fascinated with like
food history and stuff like that so any
time that any like Netflix puts up
anything I'm gonna [__] watch it
Jaguar says they don't have it no dude
man [__] contact me later
I'll give you a recipe you could do it
with pork but really should be done with
beef you would love that I mean pork's
good too yeah that's kind of like
or both yeah
yeah both at the same time go for a meat
explosion oh by the way what
just remembered this before the show
started
Tony and elata offered asked us if they
wanted if we wanted to come meet them
and hang out with them as secrets
wait where is that
it's in this area
that's a kind of like a clothing
optional couple's Hotel
like I've heard of it but I didn't know
where it was they said they've been
hanging out there they have a good time
and she's like you don't have to be nude
you just and then [__] you now Tony is
Jenny could wear her bathing suit
my baby's suit in high heels he goes
yeah yeah
that's what they've been doing down
there you didn't even like ask me about
this no it's not the first time yeah I
was like Jenny go for it she's kind of
like uptight about that kind of [__] I'm
not uptight I just don't want people
looking at my fat ass that's what
they're gonna look at
but no he's like I don't want to Teeter
around on high heels I want to be
comfortable you guys know that is
[__] Tony later are friends of ours
for a long time ago later is my [__]
ex-girlfriend I introduced the two and
they got married yeah they've been
together longer than we have 14 years
yeah 14 years
yeah
they're just another they're they're
awesome yeah yeah there's another goth
couple I'll dig up some pictures of them
yeah I know they're asking us to go to
the singles to the cup to the couples
motel with them and it's like well you
know we kind of only really want to hang
out with people that we know you know
well yeah I mean you guys are safe you
know I'm freaking that's kind of the
thing but they've been hanging out there
for about a month instead of the clubs
they said they said they like it better
and I said you got late to go and run
around naked she goes oh yeah yeah
cool guy's there though well yeah that's
always good yeah because yeah so he's a
creepy singles everything
that's I don't know man you know how
Jenny is because oh well you know will
you change your mind oh is that what you
say about me behind my back I didn't say
it behind your back I told you face to
see how Jenny is she don't she didn't
even like wearing a short skirt well
yeah you told me that like now but you
already said it behind my back earlier
that's what that's just the way it is
I guess I don't have a picture of them
I thought we I mean I thought we had
lots of pictures of them uh I can dig
them up but I was just talking about
Zach says God that reminds me I want to
go back to the bath house sometime
yes indeed Zach I mean you know yeah
it might be fun like ask you know I'm
kind of I'm kind of drunk now so I'm
just kind of like okay maybe but they're
talking about on a Saturday I don't know
yeah I had to ask them how much they how
much they want or how much how much they
cost that's what I mean it's like that's
kind of what I'm more worried about yeah
you know than anything else
because Jenny is broke that's them right
there
it's all white oh wait there they are
yeah let's see if I
full-time dad said you too huh what um
meaning broke
if you mean broke yeah yeah I'm totally
broke yeah they're super cute yeah
they're super cute and there's like
they're super nice there's yeah yeah I
really really we just go to the club
with them all time [__] run around
and [__]
and we keep like every time we see them
we're always kind of like man you guys
need to come to the house like we live
far away from them but it's just kind of
like and then we just never set it up
because we're
lazy bums
you know what I mean
we always busy man what about these
[__] bills that's the thing it's like
I'm always working and it's just kind of
like
I don't know I just feel like I need to
take more time but I can't I feel like I
can't take more time because if I take
time then it's like I'm not making money
so yeah and I don't have enough money as
it is
so I'm always just kind of like well
gotta gotta work more that's how I solve
that you know what I mean hard Jaguar
AKA [__] kind of bots launched up in
[__] Mexico is to eat and fish he's
sending me pictures this is what I mean
that looks good yeah
man we got a good Mexican restaurant
here all the all the Farm Workers eat at
just up the road man it's just [__]
so awesome and it's like right from
Mexico
Mexican family owns it and
all Central American clientele I haven't
eaten there forever prices went up
because everything's just so expensive
now you know for as far as food
but they're [__] selling damn fresh
made Tortillas and everything got
everything Mexican grocery store Mexican
cuts of meat Mexican yeah it's like half
grocery store and half restaurant yeah
half grocery store it's like that's like
the Mexican meeting place I guess I
don't think they're all from Mexican
Mexico though well there's probably like
Central America yeah it's just Central
American but it's because it's like it's
it's a pretty big um grocery store they
got like all kinds of stuff in there but
you can get a Waka cheese you can get
anything you get Mexican Coca-Cola they
got everything over there
hard Jaguar said 18.99 got canceled God
damn it when it was only like one season
right what's 18.99 it was the same
people that did um that made dark
remember that which I which I loved so
much that German series but you didn't
watch it with me because yeah it was it
was too much to keep track of like I
said you needed a flow chart and [__]
but I still haven't watched that but so
now it's only like one season that's
some [__] okay Jaguars said that
everything's expensive over in Mexico
right now too yep we're in the
apocalypse bro
we're all gonna get a lot skinnier
it's okay with me yeah don't make
everything so dramatic I'm doing what
I'm doing this is my show
uh Zach says you should God I'd kill for
some fried fish for dinner sometime or
Lobster I need to go to Red Lobster yeah
Lobster's [__] yeah we need to go to
the Red Lobster but lobsters [__]
through the roof I you know what as far
as like kind of just mid-price uh
sit-down restaurants go I really like
Red Lobster but every single time I go
there yeah it's all it's too much food I
just can't eat it all because of all the
breading yeah it's just and even well
last time bring in [__] yeah last time
we went I tried to like I was like okay
I'm gonna get everything like steamed or
broiled or something like that I'm not
gonna get anything fried and it was
still too much I just like going because
I had to cook and and the I don't have
to cook and the food's decent it's
decent it's corporate food yeah it's
it's fine
Captain D's that's a real Southern
experience there man that will also give
you you'll need a corner like you'll
have a corn area after that yeah it's
good though Southern Southern Seafood
that's pretty much the only now I would
consider that that's more fast casual
than fast food although they do have
drive-through so you could argue either
way you can't sit down and eat in there
though
um as far as I know that's the only fast
food fast casual place that has Fried
Green Tomatoes yeah it's Southern as
[__] sweet tea and everything everybody
working in the places is African
American American they're all Southern
taking pride in that [__] [__] I
think it's a big old plate of fries
greens yeah Fried Green Tomatoes yeah
coleslaw coleslaw today sweet cornbread
cornbread cornbread yeah Greens Greens
it's a chain it's a chain but but it's
locals in there cooking it and [__]
it's like a ma and pop place you don't
really think it's such you know it
doesn't feel like a chain when you're in
there there's a lot of character comes
out through the food because they're
they're back there deep fried you know
yeah and they're making they're making
their own batters they're doing their
own deep fry they're so unhealthy but
it's yeah oh yeah Southern as [__] if
they're good you go there on a [__]
Sunday
and it's going to be the entire black
church crowd they're going to be dressed
up and they're fighting with all the
hoods and the hats suits dudes with
cowboy hats and suits and yeah
Zach says how would you rate Popeyes
Popeyes is actually pretty good probably
has the best red beans and rice you can
buy I mean everybody says that yes
indeed and they'll tell you that in the
Deep South in Mississippi Louisiana
Alabama you say red beans are rice well
you can't beat red beans that's like
trying to say you're gonna beat
McDonald's french fries yeah you're just
not really gonna be that's kind of the
gold standard right the papa Israel yeah
I used to like their po boys
but I don't think they have them anymore
last time Blake we haven't been to
Popeyes in a while they built a newer
one like by our old house so we went to
it a couple of times but I don't think
they used to have like a pretty decent
shrimp po boy but I don't think they had
it like when I was there last time
so which is a shame I usually get a
oyster Pool Boys
a couple dollars more you can get the
big oysters on them yeah I mean really
good yeah that's good too yeah but I'm
just saying I don't even think did they
even have that last time we were there I
don't remember I don't know I don't
think because if they had had it I would
have ordered it I don't even remember
that oyster po boy with lemon butter
well see that's what Zach was asking
about like what our favorite Seafood was
okay like I was like oh there's a lot of
different kinds of seafood there's no
favorite
I mean um that's why I said that's a
hard question yeah
like I like just [__] crab legs can't
crab legs great [__] um
uh [__] crawfish Louisiana Crawfish
Boil with with
potatoes and corn in it and yeah
all the lemons that's good lemons in it
yep that's good you pour all those
[__] out inside of a boat or
something like that or on the back there
on a picnic table
plastic bags and you're gonna get that
[__] dripping all down your arms and
just eat it with your whole garbage cans
to throw all the holes in your shell
them and sucking the [__] juice out
of the damn heads and throwing that over
there just it just it'll get you it'll
eat you up it'll eat you up and then
when you get hungry you get eat a potato
because you'll never get full on that
crawfish
you know you can eat 20 pounds of
crawfish and it's still not really still
be hungry it's kind of the same with
it's all [__] shell like boiled
shrimp you know what I mean it's like I
could probably eat my own weight until
the shrimp you just never you never get
full yeah but for pound for pound shrimp
has about four times the meat in it
that's true because a crawfish just
weighs so much and that Tail's so small
on it that's why you grab the [__]
head when you pull the tail off you grab
that head crush it
throw him in a [__] thing and eat a
potato [__] ninja
these pieces of corn on the cob eat that
put that down you got the [__] dripping
and it's burning
if you're around real Southerners Jenny
she's the lightweight that shit's got so
much born here you were that [__] is so
much Zatarain's in there it just burns
you up whole onions boiled in there give
me that onion you pull it here you want
something you're throwing it
foreign
yeah garlic whole garlic cloves in it
you're a southern Pretender I'm not a
pretender you weren't even born here now
I was born in California but I spent
every summer of my life [__] I spent
my whole life in this house yeah but
that was and my and my parents that was
Daytona though that's my favorite
parents were from there that's the Big
City compared to what see now we're
right now we're competing to see who is
more Southern Tennessee now we're
competing to see who is more Southern
I'm just saying I grew up okay
I grew up here
[Laughter]
I just didn't have to stay here all the
time
I enjoyed it more because I didn't but
you know I had to keep Zach says when I
lived here for many years yeah well
before the Army I lived in Mississippi
for two years before I went to the Army
that's where I learned my trade as a
cook before I went to the Army half
naked you said that noise made me cringe
that probably that one where you were
sucking this
because all the air is coming in through
the front of his [__] body and [__]
and it's [__] making this slurping
sound and you're pulling out all that
damn boiled [__] zataran
flavored juice through all of his
[__] lungs and it's trying to suck
the brains yes it's kind of like the
inside it's delicious yeah but it's kind
of like the insides of a [__] kind of
like the inside of like like eating an
oyster but it's spicy
and then oh God honestly my favorite
thing to do with oysters is put them on
the grill like yeah you know what I mean
yeah like kind of Grill them I like them
deep fried well they're good well
everything is good deep fried they're
good deep fried too I'm just saying like
grilled oysters are also good
uh Jeffy artza just got back from Publix
you guys inspired me to buy Peter Pan
peanut butter yeah buy one get one by
the way okay yeah yeah oh and a pub sub
ooh what can't you get okay oh man
public Subs okay I forget about peanut
butter you can make peanut butter
cookies with those if you got sugar and
butter and a little bit of flour and
peanut butter you can make peanut butter
cookies
I got the [__] to make it I know you do
you always say that okay I can make it
we probably got a Nutella too
do we put that on top of the peanut
butter see what she's talking about is I
made a peanut butter cookies one time
and then took the dough and put it
inside in like a cupcake cupcake thing
and we made and we baked them like baked
them like that to make a cookie cup a
cookie Cup right then you put Nutella in
there and then I put Nutella in and then
put them in the refrigerator and put
them in the refrigerator and it got hard
and it was like a cupcake made out of
peanut butter cookie with Nutella Center
I mean that [__] was good it's real good
a million calories Millions well I mean
to be fair you could really only eat one
or like right about half of one and I
was just kind of like okay they're so
rich that's enough for me
so yeah so what kind of Public Sub did
you get because public Subs
um I know they don't have Publix in
other parts of the United States
but Publix
if you're in the South makes the best
bucket zombies yeah my favorite are I
really like one it's got to be that
multigrain bread because man that Publix
multigrain bread is the [__] I love that
stuff
um and I usually get roast beef yeah I
get the roast beef and swiss and I
usually get spinach on it instead of
lettuce to make it gotta have tomatoes
on it gotta have banana peppers on it
yeah
trying to think what else I put on there
oil and vinegar but I usually have that
on the side so okay a bunch of questions
um
how about best Southern dessert says
Zach yeah there was another one before
the best Southern dessert really better
toss up Gooey Butter Cake I would say
yeah
key lime pie well yeah that's not also
known as icebox pie which is a little
bit different either one of those are
good ice box pie is the easier way to do
it
uh fantastic all right it's kind of like
key lime pie pineapple upside down cake
is yeah pineapple upside down okay uh
cocoons
[__] real good
um lemon icing cake which is a butt cake
with lemon icing on top of it that's
real oh yeah I like that too
um it's all good yeah
okay gooey butter Cake's my favorite
though she likes that I prefer peach
cobbler easy southern peach cobbler it's
only got a couple of ingredients in
there it's good I think it was a
condensed milk it's like three
ingredients well you can make it with
condensed milk Bisquick and canned
peaches yeah that's pretty much it my
grandma the easier way is self-rising
flour
butter
condensed milk and a can of peaches with
cinnamon and I think there might might
be a little bit of sugar in it too and
that's it yeah and then cook that in
cook it you can easily find that online
easy
peach cobbler it's in a cookbook too we
we have a cookbook that has it on there
and then you just either have it hot out
of the microwave because you make a
bunch of it at once but cut a square
microwave it pull it out either put
whipped cream on it or a scoop of ice
cream you can't be there that's
another one super easy super easy and
it's super cheap I mean it doesn't look
pretty no but it's good
if you want to scale it up a little bit
Southern as [__] redneck [__] food
also
soul food to Nana puddin made out of
[__] vanilla wafers Cena thank you
bananas and [__] bananas in a bowl my
grandma's and let it cure a little bit
and it's got to be cream it's got to be
Nilla wafers Nilla wafers that's right
no from Nabisco from Nabisco well you
could use the sunshine nillo you could
use the sunshine knockoffs I don't think
Sunshine is around anymore it might not
be actually I haven't seen it in a while
I haven't seen lemon coolers in a while
oh there was a southern cookie that we
[__] used to just manage I really
liked lemon cooler it was like a Nilla
Wafer but it's a little more crispy a
little harder a little more crunchier
but it had chips in it instead of
chocolate chips they were lemon chips
and the whole thing was rolled in
powdered sugar in other words icing
sugar for you ribs those were good man
they were good they were kind of like a
cocoon and then what was they came in
like a box it was like a kind of like a
smaller yeah like a green like it was
like a cereal box yeah cereal green
cereal yellow trim on it yeah I remember
that a cocoon was kind of like that
shaped like a [__] like like a like a
like a butterfly chrysalis it was white
rolled in in icing sugar or powdered
sugar and it was uh I think it was
pecans inside of like a buttery cookie
yeah and you rolled them and my
grandmother made the best ones because
man pecans like what one of my favorite
like Mass Market cookies is um pecan
sandies and yeah like pecan Sandy rolled
and but and here's it which is
shortbread it's shortbread here's the
thing though when your southern ass
grandma made them things they had so
much butter in them that the butter
would leak out into the the icing sugar
or the on the outside of it and it would
become like a glaze yeah so you could
stop stack them up in a big cookie jar
and they would be good in there you'd
reach down there and they'd come up they
wouldn't be powdery at all they'd be
more like waxy but they were delicious
delicious Southern grandmas man Southern
Grandma they put like sticks and sticks
of butter in butter and all kinds of
sugar because they knew that it tasted
better bacon grease all kinds of bacon
grease and everything this is why we're
fat if it was me if it was if it if it
was a vegetable or a meat it had bacon
grease in it oh somewhere well it either
and or it was boiled to Oblivion yeah
blood Oblivion that was another I'm
working I'm gonna [__] speak the
truth where the truth is
I'm gonna speak the truth when you
deserve to speak the truth
grant our grandmother's age this is they
were older than the Boomers
they were [__] at cooking vegetables
I think it's because during the
Depression era they may have been using
their own [__]
uh Outhouse [__] sludge to fertilize
the crops outside their [__] shotgun
shack that's where a lot of [__] comes
from
so they were paranoid about getting
diseases so they just overcooked
vegetables they just wanted to make sure
you just turned it into [__] slime
like I didn't
they would take spinach and turn it into
a green slime they're [__] terrible I
told you I didn't realize that spinach
was actually good until I was in my 20s
terrible
um because growing up it just looked
like Snot yeah terrible they just boiled
the [__] out of it boiled everything to
[__] death it tasted like nothing the
only thing that they really cooked well
were things when it came to vegetables
was
boiling corn corn on the cob
that came out right
uh
grains came out right a bunch of collard
greens yeah they came out good they
didn't overcook those
turnip greens also uh uh diced turnips
came out good
fried okra came out good
boiled potatoes of course and baked
potatoes I mean it's hard to bounce that
hard to be honest but um what else was
that they came out that they could do
that was pretty good oh Fried Green
Tomatoes they did that pretty good other
than that Tomatoes were just served red
they turned them into sauce and canned
them
um my grandma used to just like slice
them and put them on a plate or like
some cottage cheese that's right it was
just like raw yeah tomato a fresh tomato
was like a food group yeah here eat that
tomato yeah it just sliced it yeah she
would just put out a plate like with
dinner with all the sides it would just
be a plate with like sliced raw tomato
and then there'd be like a little bowl
of like cottage cheese yeah and your
relatives is a little give me remember
matters give me some Tomatoes they
[__] pull the Tomato on our plate and
just start cutting it yeah and eating it
yeah
maybe put salt on it yeah sometimes
just different time I've seen them also
just take it like an apple and just
start eating off it foot salt yeah take
a nap
which is funny I wasn't a big fan of
tomatoes when I was growing up but I
really like them now
so Jeffy art sub from Publix roast beef
turkey and ham on wheat bread with
spinach Mayo mustard tomatoes and onions
yeah oil and vinegar yeah you want the
yellow American cheese pepper that
sounds really you want the spinach you
know uh you don't want the lettuce
because the lettuce makes everything too
[__] soggy
well plus I kind of feel like I don't
know the spinach like gives it a little
something something yeah it gives it
like more flavor yeah full-time dead our
circle king girl says try the London
Broil roast beef with havarti Dill from
Publix trust me you won't be
disappointed that actually does sound
really good
yeah then Jeff yard said paired with a
glass of Pinot Noir because me fancy oh
and the pickle slices yeah you really
because man I love pickles pickles and
banana peppers I don't like anything I
don't like like jalapenos on it because
it's
like I said I've never been a fan of
like super super hot
spicy food
um Knox I don't like it it's just that
it usually it doesn't agree with me okay
so uh I can't really eat and especially
like the older I get because you know
I'm 50 now so it's just kind of like I
can't really eat stuff that's like super
super spicy or I'm gonna regret it
so
um yeah so I don't really eat but I do
really like
pickles I like banana peppers that's
probably like the hottest that I get on
there
but you know like I said we usually go
to Publix and get them and then if you
ask for the dressing on the side
then you can just put it on when you get
home so it doesn't get all because if
you put it on in the store it tends to
like
make the bread slightly soggy but I mean
I don't mind that because their subs are
so good otherwise but
usually I just get it on the side
Zach says uh pecan sandies were my
Grandma's favorite cookies
yeah they're I mean they're so good I
mean shortbread with pecans in it you
can't mess that up I'm sorry basic as
[__] but I let Grandma eat Foods she
never had ribbon candy though yeah I'm
not I mean ribbon candy is fine it's you
know honestly I'm not a big fan now I do
have a bunch of
uh candy canes over there from Christmas
that were actually on the Christmas tree
because I love peppermint but I'm not a
big fan of like hard candy I like some
hard candy I like like werthers I know
that's another Grandma thing
and
I'll eat Lifesavers but on the whole if
I'm gonna eat candy I would rather it be
chocolate preferably with nuts in it
actually most preferably I would like it
to be white chocolate with nuts in it
actually Tom got me for Christmas I
didn't even they made these they were
the lint they were the lint truffles
right yeah he got me a bag of like these
lit Truffles and they were white
chocolate and the cream inside was
Snickerdoodle yeah they're good
those were [__] outside sugar cookie
ones those were so white chocolate sugar
cookie was good too I had to like
prevent myself from eating the whole bag
at once yeah they were so good man
Snickerdoodle and actually like we just
got
um because I think we talked about this
before like the little Debbies which are
kind of like oatmeal pies which I'm not
a huge fan of like I'll eat them but
they're not my favorite but they did a
version that was like Snickerdoodle
they're smaller than the oatmeal pies
but they're like snickerdoodle cookies
with like kind of hunks of cinnamon in
there and they have like that kind of
I don't is it marshmallow in the middle
inside what inside the Snickerdoodle
thing yeah marshmallow cream is it it's
the same as the same it tastes like
vanilla e no it's the same as what's
inside uh
the Little Debbie Oatmeal cookie pies
Sam
I just there's more of it it just seems
like more volume it's smaller though
it's a smaller cookie yeah so maybe
they're good though it's like the yeah I
really like those like I said I don't
love the oatmeal pies but future says he
can't believe you're you're in your 50s
you thought you were in your 30s like
37. oh I feel 50 believe me but thank
you
sometime well not not usually like
sometimes I do though sometimes I wake
up and be like uh she's so old pretty
good anti-aging genetics her mom still
looks pretty young her mom looks like a
Pia Zadora
yeah my mom is well let's see
68 68 coming up on 70. she her mom still
looks pretty youthful
and um you know she does exercises and
you know we do hormone replacement type
stuff and
but it's a mixture of everything
I mean you know we don't go out in the
sun all that much we don't do I mean we
do we drink a lot but
it's honestly just on the show we don't
smoke anymore
yeah kind of smaller portions now I mean
we both put on weight there for a little
while when I was getting it going
[__] wild just making all kinds of
[__] we I was over feeding myself and
her
and then I realized that women their
metabolism moves so much more slowly
than guys because they just their
hormones aren't quite the same well I
tried to tell you women and honestly you
gotta really under feed them yeah well
and it's not I mean it's not just women
in general it's just it's me because
it's just like my well the genetics yeah
because I was talking to
um just a couple months ago I was
talking to my sister my brothers and my
brothers said the same exact thing
they're like we basically have to stay
under 1500 calories or we will be 500
pounds
you know what I mean and that's not a
lot for a guy and my and my brothers are
you know considerably taller than me
because I'm pretty short but yeah they
have the same thing where it's just like
man we just got I you know in back in
the old days it probably would have been
good genetics because it's like oh well
you know you could live a lot longer if
you didn't have anything to eat but with
the Civil War in in modern times not so
much like now you just kind of like walk
by a cupcake yeah and five pounds
somehow attaches itself to your ass
so during the Civil War the South got
basically starved out
um a lot of there was lots and lots of
starvation
a lot of people got wiped out a lot uh
if you go on uh rageaholic there's a
dude named razorfish just a couple days
ago he posted a thing on Lincoln first
American dictator and he pulls up all
this
actual witness testimony and um things
that happened in old news articles and
there was damn near an attempted
genocide on the South during that war
I guess the civilians and everything
because of all the embargoes and the
blockades food stopped showing up there
wasn't anybody really planting
so there was a lot of starvation
uh the people that survived the
starvation had slower metabolism they
were kind of like yeah fat ass
[__] yeah and they tended to be
shorter which those genes kind of work
together just to ask Mexico Mexicans are
short and they're just
famine proof they don't need
very many calories to to live on I told
you everything you feed them they get
bit they get dig around the middle all
right which is
cons on there you know he he he's
actually very tall and large for a
Mexican guy but he'll tell you the same
thing the Mexicans the southerners can
put on weight easily
and it's harder to starve us out we
don't need as much to survive like I
said I could probably live on my fat
reserves for several months yeah
so we're shorter and put on weight
so we got to kind of beat watch it
my endocrine system is so jacked up
though I I don't have to do that as much
as I used to
I can burn anything I'm like a teenager
but
in on my normal configuration if I
wasn't doing HRT and other anabolics and
[__]
I'd be a skinny fat little [__]
probably because I was starting to put
all weight
when my metabolism started to slow down
in my late 40s
you get fat quick man
well five pounds looks like 30 on a dude
that's only five six
that's another thing if you're shorter
and you can't like if you're a tall
person you can gain some weight and it's
like you don't want to see it yeah yeah
it won't like show up as much because
it'll be evenly distributed but short
ass [__] like us yeah you gain
like a pound or two and everybody's like
man you're getting kind of like chunky
yeah all those Wars between the Mexican
city-states you know and the [__]
Aztec domination of the uh of their
empire and the other city-states there
was a lot of problems with plague and
they kind of have the same genetics as
we have short and fat if you're not
careful
I mean yeah well I mean you really gotta
watch it yeah you're really gonna watch
gotta watch and yeah I mean I'm only I'm
five foot three
on the besties some you know five foot
two usually if you measure me like first
thing in the morning
but yeah holy [__] I go
over 1200 calories a day
I start putting weight on yeah and it's
you know my siblings are all the same
pretty much all of the uh women on my
mom's side of the family which is
interesting because they're not quite as
Southern they from more of the Baltimore
area
but uh they're all built exactly the
same as me they're kind of like shorter
you know five five and under
um big thighs big butt big calves tiny
feet tiny hands
and just gain weight very very easily so
you know Victor says staying out of the
sun is key I've always uh worked nights
and I wear sunscreen if I gotta be out
and about during the day yeah I mean I'm
not a big fan of being out in the
daytime anyway it's just never been my
thing yeah so yeah Louie and
connovathlon they're they're Mexicans
once ones in Mexico the other ones in in
California these are those are they're
just talking about right those are big
guys for Mexico's Louis 6-1 and I think
and and I think uh kind of Barcelona are
also uh name he's using now it's hard
Jaguar I think he's about that too about
six feet
you know I've showed him before and
everything got some handsome Sons his
sons look like he's ready for [__]
Hollywood look at the Rat Pack
all right but uh yeah they got big
Mexicans but they had big Mexicans back
then
you guys descended from the ones that
were doing all the heart cutting out on
top of the damn temples
the little worker bee a little work
could be Mexicans they got smaller and
smaller and smaller because you always
wanted to sacrifice your most valuable
people to the gods to make sure that the
[__] Sun would move so they tended to
be the taller worker bees
so if you were shorter you you would
evade getting your [__] heart cut out
but that was just religion of the time
you know
that's how we always escaped getting
yeah right well I think even nobody
notices because we were like tiny and
short I think even I think even Cortez
mentioned some [__] like that if I
remember is it the Cortez or was one of
the Friars later on
that the the ruling class and the
warrior class because they had different
Warrior Cults you know like Eagle Eagle
Warriors and other ones I forgot what
they were right offhand I've been
drinking but that they were bigger than
your um your average work worker B
Mexican is what they would call her
Mexico over that time
and then there was the the city-states
that they had kind of
uh is put enthrall during their empire
they helped pay off the blood debt yeah
it was [__] great culture man that's
some Macho [__] man [__] time was
that [__] I love that [__] yeah unless
that's straight out of Conan straight
out of Conan sacrifice next kids are
[__] Conan [__] but
Zach says so is everybody else Madden
well yeah the Islanders were like that
too
you know and [__] white people were
like that back in the day it was just
you know back when we were true to
ourselves
the Vikings and [__] sacrificing people
Romans over there saying get in that
damn Arena [__] put on a good show
this is professional sports here people
it's all the same [__] same thinking
Zach said there's a company called
American Dream nut Butters they have a
peanut and almond and cashew Butters
that have chunks of stuff in them like
different candies and cookies it sounds
amazing that actually really does sound
amazing to be honest with you yeah
um yeah
we had didn't Tammy was it Tammy that
sent us the jar of like the ground up
cookie butter
it was like the ground up
what are those cookies called little
white those little white cookies those
little like tea cookies yeah that are
like they're not like super super sweet
no no no no no no
what were they called
those oval [__] long yeah yeah
cookies like like I said the ones you
eat with tea yeah it was like that it's
like those tea bits like those biscuits
or those cookie
without any frosting just ground up and
put into something that was kind of like
a like a buttery spread this [__] was
looking great and it would kind of
crunch a little bit it was a little bit
gritty like little cookie pieces in it
man that was so good yeah
yeah I ate that [__] on toast yeah so
good
Louie says his nephew's six three or six
four damn they're getting bigger man the
Mexicans are getting bigger
gotta put it into that
yeah Louie said I think we're the ones
with a little more Spanish blood yeah my
mom is five foot two and my father is
about five foot eight yeah my uncle's on
my mom's side were tall though genetics
are weird yeah yeah kinda want to admit
it man but I'm looking at them he looked
Khan looks very European to me
but you know it's just that's what
happened that's that's what that was the
that was the makeup of Mexico
you know you had miss stitzo you had
more Indian and then you had uh more
European Spanish you know the Spanish
were [__] badasses babe you know they
were basically Germans really especially
Northern Spain the castilians
they were they were big the Spanish
Empire was [__] huge man it's much
bigger than the British Empire at one
point
and uh they were good Traders you know
trading and shipping all through the 14
to 1500s badass technology
and um
you know say what you will
they [__] made Central and South
America what it is and Central South and
Central America they made it what it is
today for better or worse
I think for better
uh technology Reading Writing different
kind of infrastructure
and kind of modernized it back in the 15
1600s that gave it a boost in a way
um
just an interesting time man when all
that happened La conquista you know
it all kind of worked out kinda but
that's just the way history is
everything kind of works out kinda you
know nothing's perfect to be honest on
either side of my family I can't think
of anybody that was particularly tall
yeah my mom is the same height as me
my dad is probably
I think he's only an inch or two taller
than you so he's only probably like five
seven five eight yeah he was a little
bit taller than me but not that much my
now my brothers are taller than me but
not they're not like super super tall my
sister is shorter than I am
by maybe like an inch or two
but yeah I don't really remember anybody
being like super tall yeah
everybody in my family is like pretty
like at like average to Short
you know
and I remember when I was in high school
one thing that stood out to me was that
because I was in uh chorus and when they
would put us like for the photo for the
yearbook and they would put you all it's
like oh we're gonna put you in height
order I was always the second from
last because I was the second shortest
it was one girl that was shorter than me
she was like four foot eleven but I was
the second shortest like everybody else
was like the [__] and I never thought
of myself as particularly short but I
guess I was
you know yeah Louis says it also depends
on what part of Mexico you're from
there's parts of Mexico where there's
Mexicans with blue eyes I have green
eyes myself one of my uncles has blue
eyes yeah
ish Khan said is Jack Parsons real
well he was yeah he's dead now so he's
not really that was uh that was the
rocket the rocket guy from Scientology
right yeah no right Jack Parsons yeah
didn't he blow up during that that
explosion when L Ron Hubbard was there
or Helen Hubbard was [__] around with
him oh I don't know about that and then
he blew himself up with rocket fuel I
don't remember that I mean maybe he did
blow himself up yeah I think that's what
he's talking about I mean he's real in
the sense that he existed but he doesn't
exist anymore because he died yeah so
there's that so you want to shut it down
Jen we've been doing this for about
three hours probably I guess how long
has it been three hours okay two hours
59 minutes yeah I'll make it some
seconds okay
yeah that was a moon child experience
yeah Ron Hubbard stole his wife yeah
that's right yeah I forgot about that
yeah I thought so yeah Michelle Ron
Hubbard and uh oh uh what's his name was
there Anton laveyard yeah yeah all of
them were [__] yeah which is dudes
inventing religions yeah yeah well you
know they all got together hey it worked
yeah
even though everybody knows they got
together and was like hey let's start a
religion yeah it's all scams well duh he
had the best one though
like I said it worked yeah it worked
you know I guess you never go poor like
underestimating how stupid people are
but you know yep okay go ahead go ahead
and shut it down shut that [__] down Jim
okay shut that [__] there well now I'm
gonna pause just because you think that
you're in charge
well I know you do that anyway
I gotta get down here and start [__]
cooking what you making
I don't know I gotta get down there and
I'll see what it is okay he doesn't yeah
I don't know yet we'll find it it'll be
a surprise it'll be a surprise all right
so have a good rest of your Friday night
you guys have a good day tomorrow we
will see you guys again on Sunday at 6
p.m Eastern Standard time we will do
another movie review not sure what movie
we're gonna do yet we'll see what the
patrons vote for and that's what we're
going to be talking about
so we'll see you guys then thanks for
dropping by thanks for super chats good
night